So, da bin ich und morgen kürzere Runde gerannt als sonst, weil scheiß Wetter, Überschwemmung am Main, zwischendurch musste ich aufs Klo und irgendwie waren meine Beine noch zu mitgenommen vom Freitag, also bin ich heute nur 7,8 oder sowas gerannt, ne 7,3 sogar nur.
7,3, ich hab übelst langsam gestartet, weil ich gedacht hab, ich mach heute ganz normal eine lange Runde und dann hab ich zwischendurch gemerkt, dass es sackt und hab Gas gegeben, also war wieder ungefähr genauso schnell wie sonst.
Moin, Anpil, der ist schon für den Sub. Moin, ich muss aber kurz warten, bis meine Nase aufhört zu laufen, weil nach dem Rennen ist immer ein bisschen alles noch am Schwitzen, wobei ich...
Ich bin seit, keine Ahnung, knapp 10 Minuten oder so daheim, also ich bin schon ein bisschen abgekühlt wieder.
Naja, übrigens, am Anfang, jetzt mal, was ist ganz was anderes? Ich hab euch schon lange nicht mehr erzählt, dass C++ ultra kacke ist, oder? Kann das sein?
Soll ich nochmal kurz mich ein bisschen aufregen über C++? Ich glaub, ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr drüber hergezogen, was das für eine Kacksprache ist, Alter.
Und zwar...
Moment, ich muss, ich muss mein...
Ich bin hochgradig verwirrt, weil irgendwie meine Notizen nicht...
Okay, keine Ahnung, warum meine Notizen... Hab ich mein Notizprogramm hier irgendwie uninstalled oder sowas?
Kacknoob?
Äh, anscheinend, okay.
Bin ich ganz sicher, warum, aber okay.
Okay, wie dem auch sei.
Also, die Primers.
Die Primers am Start, ja.
Danke, Leute, für die Subs.
BlackHD, POG-Subscription.
Ich glaub, ich hab das auf dem zweiten Rechner uninstalled, dass ich nicht durcheinander komme.
Auf beiden, wo ich was, wo ich was genotet hab.
Dabei ist das eigentlich komplett unsinnig, weil ich den Kram gesynkt habe, zumindest.
Naja, egal.
Wie dem auch sei, ist auch wurscht.
Also, Leute, mir ist mal wieder aufgefallen, wie abgrundtief kacke C++ ist.
Und ich bin diesmal nicht drauf gekommen...
Also, ich seh nicht so, als wäre das jetzt was Neues, ja.
Und ich bin diesmal nicht drauf gekommen, weil ich mal wieder ein bisschen Microcontroller programmiert habe.
Da fällt mir das ja in der Regel auf, weil da kommst du um C++ nicht rum, gerade wenn's in ESP ist.
Und letztendlich ist es ja irgendeine Mischung aus ESP, quasi Standardlibraries in C, plus oben drüber ein bisschen Arduino-Zeug, C++.
Also, da fällt einem relativ früh auf, dass es sagt, obwohl das ja eigentlich eines der Anwendungszwecke schlechthin für C++ ist.
Nein, wobei mir das aufgefallen ist, ist...
Und ihr werdet echt den Kopf schütteln jetzt.
Also, zumindest jeder, der da nicht den Kopf schüttelt, der muss übelster C++-Fan sein, wenn man das sich schönreden kann.
Und zwar, ich hab ein C++-Talk angefangen zu gucken.
Undefined Behavior.
So, da sind Beispiele...
Wir gucken uns den jetzt nicht an, ja.
Also, keine Sorge, wir gucken uns keine...
Alfred, danke schön für den Sub.
Keine Sorge, wir gucken uns keine...
32... Hier, hier ist es.
Wir gucken uns keine 32 Minuten...
C++ an.
Aber, ich hab mal eine ernst gemeinte Frage an euch.
Warum ist das, was er jetzt gleich zeigt, Undefined Behavior?
Guckt euch das mal an.
So.
Ja.
Warum ist das um alles in der Welt Undefined Behavior?
Warum?
Es ist eine Command-Line-Ausgabe, die bevorprintet mit einem U-Line dahinter.
Danach kommt eine Endlosschleife, weil I gleich 1, Endlosschleife.
Und in C ist ja, sag mal, alles ungleich 0, true.
So, Endlosschleife.
Und danach After.
So, und jetzt kommt der Witz.
Älterer Compiler printet before und hängt.
Etwas neuerer Compiler, in dem Fall ist der Unterschied zwischen Clang oder wie auch immer man das gescheit ausspricht.
Manche sagen C-Lang, manche sagen Clang und GCC.
Und GCC printet, und jetzt haltet euch fest, GCC printet before, dann aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann es die Endlosschleife beenden und printet after.
Und der Witz ist, mittlerweile bei neueren GCC-Versionen haben sie das auch eingebaut.
So.
Warum um alles in der Welt ist sowas Undefined Behavior?
Sowas sollte kein Undefined Behavior sein.
Der Compiler optimiert die Schleife weg.
Das kann der Compiler meinetwegen machen, solange das Kompilierte vom Verhalten gleich dem ist, was da steht.
Ich hab nix gegen Optimierungen, die aufs gleiche Ergebnis führen.
Und zweitens, warum ist das Undefined Behavior und wenn es nicht erlaubt ist, kein Compiler-Fehler?
Warum ist es kein Compile-Error, wenn es nicht erlaubt ist?
Es macht absolut keinen Sinn.
Jeder normale Mensch, der sich dieses Programm anguckt, sagt dir, was passiert.
Der sagt, es wird before geprintet und dann hängt es.
Alles andere ist absoluter Bullshit.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
So, und die Erklärung dazu in dem Vortrag ist leider ein bisschen mau.
Aber die Erklärung ist typisch C++-Schwachsinn.
Und zwar, weil...
Pass mal auf.
Blablabla.
An dem Moment, hier war es ja schon.
So, also guckt euch mal an.
Also GCC 9 macht das, was man erwartet.
Und GCC 10, also die bessere Version im Endeffekt,
printet das, was man komplett nicht erwartet.
So, both results are valid,
weil Infinite Loop ist undefined behavior per standard.
So, da fangen wir jetzt erstmal an.
Warum ist eine Infinite Loop undefined behavior?
Eine Infinite Loop ist vollkommen normal.
Selbst ohne Abbruchsbedingungen, meinetwegen.
Es ist jetzt vielleicht nichts, was man unbedingt best practice mäßig machen sollte,
aber es ist definitiv kein fucking undefined behavior, eine Infinite Loop.
Wie kann man so dämlich sein?
Eine Endlosschleife ist vollkommen okay.
Eine Endlosschleife ist kein undefined behavior, eine Endlosschleife ist eine Endlosschleife.
So, und dementsprechend ist die zweite Frage, die zweite Frage ist,
warum muss ein Stoff,
ein Standard überhaupt irgendwas hier dazu sagen?
Ich meine, das ist okay, wenn die Standards irgendwas zu den einzelnen Konstrukten sagen,
also wie gesagt, zu einer Endlosschleife,
aber es muss, es sollte ernsthaft kein Blick in den Standard notwendig sein,
um zu erkennen, was dieses Programm macht.
Es ist komplett logisch vom Programmfluss,
dass After nie angezeigt wird, weil das eine Endlosschleife ist.
Alles andere ist,
wie soll man sagen, eine riesen Diskrepanz zwischen, was da steht, was programmiert wurde versus das,
was am Ende ausgeführt wurde und das soll keine Programmiersprache haben.
Ja, es ist doch auch nicht so, dass, das ist, das ist fast schon so, wie wenn Console.WriteLine
auf einmal das gleiche macht wie Console.ReadLine.
Sowas hier, in den Größenordnungen.
Es steht was da und es passiert was komplett anderes.
Ja klar gibt's Break.
Klar ist Break, klar gibt's ein Break.
Deswegen, selbst eine, selbst eine Endlosschleife ohne Abbruchbedingungen
ist vielleicht nicht die schönste Variante, die es gibt,
aber das ist kein undefined behavior, das ist okay.
So und das ist halt echt wieder so das Ding, wo ich mir denke,
was zum Teufel machen die C++-Standard-Dinger?
Die haben es ja noch schlimmer gemacht, weil anscheinend am Anfang war das hier wirklich undefined behavior.
Ja, das ist ja noch schlimmer gemacht, weil anscheinend am Anfang war das hier wirklich undefined behavior.
Weil es nirgendwo defined war.
Und dementsprechend haben die Compiler-Implementierer das Logische gemacht, es hängen zu lassen.
Aber irgendwann sind die am Standard auch noch auf die Idee gekommen, irgendwas dazu reinzuschreiben.
Wobei man sich halt echt fragen muss, wie kann etwas undefined behavior sein,
wenn es defined ist im Standard als undefined behavior.
Das widerspricht sich ja selbst schon.
Das hat Theod... Theod... Du... Äh... Ja, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Du hast vollkommen recht.
Ja, du hast vollkommen recht.
Theoretisch... Theoretisch könnte ein anderer Thread, wenn man einen gestartet...
Das wird er bestimmt nicht erkennen, je nachdem wie verwurstet man den startet.
Ja, du hast vollkommen recht.
Theoretisch könnte ein anderer Thread das ändern und dann...
Wobei, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das geht in C++, weil...
An der Stelle, weil...
What the fuck, wo habe ich es denn?
Ich würde fast sagen...
Äh...
Leute, bin ich jetzt dumm?
Ich würde fast sagen, in C++ wird es wahrscheinlich schwierig.
Hier in...
Weil, wenn du einen neuen Thread startest, kannst du darauf überhaupt noch zugreifen?
Oder kannst du den...
Kannst du den value nur...
Kannst du das nur bei value, bei copy value irgendwie in den Thread kriegen, das Ding, weil es kein Pointer ist?
Wobei doch, das ist eine globale Variable über main, das müsste eigentlich gehen, ja?
Aber nicht so ganz...
Ganz...
Doch, doch, ich glaube das geht.
Ja, aber du hast...
Du hast recht.
Und selbst wenn nicht, funktioniert es vielleicht zum Dreiecken.
Es ist komplett dämlich.
Es macht so keinen Sinn, dass das undefined behavior ist.
Also, also, erstens, dass das...
Dass es überhaupt defined werden muss, dass es undefined behavior ist.
Und, dass was komplett unvorhergesehen ist, passiert.
Das ist wieder echt für mich so ein prime example auf, wie beschissen kann man eine Sprache designen.
So.
Danach habe ich übrigens nicht weiter geguckt, weil mich das schon wieder so aufgeregt hat.
Ja klar, ja klar, ja klar gibt es das.
Endlosschleifen ist vollkommen okay.
Wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt immer die beste Idee sein, eine Endlosschleife zu machen, ganz ohne Abbruchbedingungen.
Aber das kann schon Sinn machen, gerade wie du sagst, bei irgendeinem Microcontroller, wo halt das am Anfang irgendwie ein bisschen initialisiert.
Und dann macht es halt wirklich endlos irgendwelches main loop input polling, ohne jegliche Abbruchsbedingungen.
Die Abbruchbedingung ist, das Ding verliert Strom so nach dem Motto, ja du stichst den Strom raus, ja dann bricht es automatisch ab.
Du brauchst nicht...
Also ich finde, eine Endlosschleife ist kein undefined behavior.
Was ist da los?
Naja.
Wollte ich jetzt an der Stelle nur mal loswerden, weil mir da aufgefallen ist, was für eine abgrundtief beschissene Sprache C++ ist.
Ja und noch schlimmer ist, das ändert sich auch noch zwischen GCC9 und GCC10, ja.
Du denkst dir nichts böses bei.
Auf einmal ist deine...
Ist deine Firmware kaputt, weil du sie mit GCC10 kompilierst.
Und eines der Sachen, was sie in C++ ja immer sagen ist, oh wir können den ganzen alten Scheiß nicht entfernen, weil die Leute verlassen sich ja drauf, dass unser Legacy Bullshit immer noch da ist.
Aber das können wir mal nebenbei ändern, ja.
So eines der elementarsten Programmflow Sachen.
Das können wir ändern.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Das ändern wir mal zwischen GCC9 und GCC10.
RealAgentSmith, danke für den Sub.
Ja, das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen.
Es ist einfach so Bullshit, man.
Das fuckt mich so ab, wenn ich das sehe.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich keinen Bock auf C++ in irgendeiner Art und Weise mache.
Warum ich lieber Sachen, auch wenn es gute C++-Libraries gibt, lieber die Sachen dann quasi irgendwie mir irgendeine Rust-Library raussuche, die das gleiche macht.
Dagegen dann, ja, super entspannter Aufwachstream.
Wofür steht GCC?
Moment, Moment, wo ist das Emote?
Wo haben wir das Emote?
Moment.
Wofür könnte GCC stehen?
Das G vor allem.
Für was könnte das G stehen?
Also ich kann es euch sagen, das steht für, ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt so, ich habe jetzt so wichtig getan, ich weiß es gar nicht hundertprozentig.
Es steht für irgendwas mit GNU Compiler.
Moment, Moment Leute, lasst mich mal kurz gucken.
Ah, GNU Compiler.
GNU Compiler.
Nee.
Collection.
GCC.
GNU Compiler Collection.
Ich wusste aus dem Ding, was mit GNU Compiler ist.
Collection.
Warum haben wir den?
Warum haben wir den einmal in, achso, das ist ein anderer Channel.
Das ist aber schlecht freigestellt hier.
Ja, es ist einfach wir.
Also die Sprache ist einfach echt Bullshit.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz meine VM starten.
Und Package-Updates machen.
Linux, by the way.
Hat sicherlich wieder 3000 Updates.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass es eine Sicherheitslücke in der, was war das?
In dem Trusted, in dem EFI Trusted Module Ding, oh nee, fuck, wie heißt das?
Egal.
Also das Teil, was benutzt wird, um Secure Boot mit was anderem als Windows zu machen.
Diesem, diesem Secure Boot Weiterleitungs-Ding.
Gab's, gab's einen ziemlich großen, ja genau, genau, das meine ich.
Gab's einen ziemlich großen Bug.
Vielleicht mal gucken, ob wir hier die Updates für kriegen.
Wobei, wir verwenden, wir verenden, wir verenden vor allem.
Wir beenden, ey, ich kann nicht mehr aussprechen, Alter.
Verenden, wir beenden, wir verwenden, wollte ich sagen, Alter.
Es ist im Deboot.
Das klappt nur bei ganz bestimmten Mainboards, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab nur mal kurz das Ganze überflogen.
Aber solchen Low-Level-Sachen einfach Update gut ist.
Das ist auch eine so eine schöne Sache an Linux.
Gerade an Arch Linux kriegst du die Updates immer super schnell.
Cuemo hat eine neue Version.
Ich hoffe, der vmchamp tut noch.
Oh, bei der Gelegenheit kann ich gerade mal kurz pullen.
Git pull origin master.
Bam.
Ich hab ein bisschen geupdatet.
Dann machen wir heute Mittag.
Nicht zu früh versprechen, aber dann machen wir heute Mittag weiter.
Romantline stellt's.
Der punchchamp.
Machen wir mal kurz Hour.
Updates.
Was sagt die Arch?
Jetbrains.
Jetbrains Toolbox, hat die irgendwelche Updates?
Nee.
Whistle Studio Code wurde geupdatet.
Auf 186.1.
Wird schon nicht so viel getan haben.
So.
Wisst ihr, da weißt ihr mehr.
Ich hab mir das so genau gar nicht angeguckt.
Habt ihr euch das genauer angeschaut.
Ich hab nur gesehen, irgendwelche Low-Level-Sachen.
Habe ich gleich mal Update nachgeschoben.
Ob ich da in der VM betroffen bin, ist eh fraglich.
So, ich muss mal kurz hier meine Jacke zumachen.
Was?
Wir reden von was anderem.
Ich rede von...
Ich rede hier von...
Lokal und aus der Ferne ausnutzbar.
Ja.
Also das schwankt zwischen 8,3 und 9,8.
Score.
Beispielsweise durch einen männlichen Mittelangriff auf den Datenverkehr für die Brandverneintnisse von HTTP-Boot.
Also irgendwie...
Was ist denn HTTP-Boot?
Ist das TFTP nur neuer oder wie?
Lokale Ausnutzung möglich.
Möglich bootfähigen USB-Stick.
Ja, aber dann muss der dann doch ran.
Dann muss der dann aber doch ran.
Ja.
Muss auch lokal sein.
Ich meine, ein Rechner bootet nicht einfach mal random von irgendeinem Server.
Im Internet.
Okay, wir haben geupdatet.
Dann machen wir mal schnell...
Reboot.
Systemd-Boot.
Giga-Chat.
Giga-Chat-Boot-D.
Kann man übrigens streiten, ob das ganze Systemd-Zeug so Giga-Chat ist.
Take Viagra, die hard IQ-Boost. Nice.
So muss das sein.
So kann ich nur sagen.
Nice.
Excellent.
Ah ja, für den Fall der Fälle, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, ich zeige euch das jetzt nochmal.
Es gibt jetzt seit einem der neuesten Systemd-Versionen, gibt es jetzt ein Feature, worauf alle gewartet haben.
Und zwar Systemd handelt Blue-Screens.
Ich habe hier gar kein Bild.
Ja.
Systemd kann seit Ende letzten Jahres Blue-Screens.
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Systemd-BSOD.
Warum ist mein Darkreader der Meinung, dass das ausgehen soll?
Endlich, ja.
Sehe ich auch so.
Ich bin echt froh, dass es jetzt soweit ist.
Ich wusste gar nicht, was ich ohne gemacht habe.
Jetzt...
Ich meine, das ist erforderlich.
Ja, das ist der Fall.
Das ist das Jahr des Desktops, des Gliedungs-Desktops wird.
Hast du mitbekommen, jemand hat sich fritz.box-Domain gesichert?
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Kommst du auf irgendeine NFT-Krypto-Seite raus?
Anscheinend nicht.
Ja, fritz.box.
Das liegt daran, dass es jetzt neue Domains gibt, .box.
Wir haben gestern auch schon, äh, nicht gestern, letzte Woche auch schon nachgeguckt.
Es ist noch sehr viel frei.
Aber ich werde mir keine .box-Domain kaufen.
Wollten wir ja just for fun eine holen.
Wobei es eigentlich ganz, ganz cool ist.
Kannst halt komplett mit Krypto-Sachen bezahlen.
Und angeblich 100 Dollar Lifetime.
Und mit .box kannst du sicherlich coole Domains machen.
Wenn du einen externen DNS hast, wie jetzt.
Denn DNS brauchst du immer.
Ach so, du meinst, die liefern keinen mit.
Du hast kein Ding, machst halt einfach auf Cloudflare.
Ja.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob das frei ist.
Warte mal.
Wo war denn diese komische Seite hier?
my.box, genau.
Search for keks.box.
Also ich werde mir das nicht registrieren.
Nicht keks.box, keks.
120.
Ah, ist das gestiegen?
Oder war das letztes Mal auch schon 120?
Also ich werde mir keine .box-Domain registrieren jetzt.
Unavailable.
Ich mache das nicht auf jetzt.
Wer weiß, wo man da rauskommt.
So, wir machen das jetzt mal weg.
Genug C++-Shit.
Was wendet denn so auf Shithub?
Lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Trending Weekly.
AI, AI, AI, AI wahrscheinlich.
Werde ich das Recht, die zu verkaufen?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Die Seite, auf der wir gerade gewesen sind.
my.box.
Was auch immer dahinter steht.
Kein Schimmer, habe ich mir nicht genau angeguckt.
Hast du eigentlich Nvidia-Stongs?
Vermutlich sind in dem ETF Nvidia-Stongs drinne.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Durchaus möglich.
Aber ich habe nicht direkt Nvidia-Stongs.
Warum?
Gehen Nvidia-Stongs gerade voll ab?
Ich guck mal.
Ich guck mal kurz.
Also ich meine, die Stongs sind mega.
Sind mega gerade.
Ich habe plus 6000 Euro innerhalb von einem Jahr schon.
Also ich meine, wenn ich es verkaufen würde.
Was ich ja nicht mache.
Ich guck mal kurz.
Nvidia.
Wow.
Alter.
Also ja, kann man so sagen.
Nvidia ging richtig ab.
Nvidia war vor ein paar Jahren noch bei irgendwie 80 Dollar.
Und jetzt 620.
Alter, die gehen aber voll steil.
Was macht eigentlich?
Nur mal so, just for fun.
Was macht denn eigentlich?
Ist wieder.
Was macht Facebook denn geiles?
Jetzt kommen die ganzen Stongs-Leute hier.
Welchen hast du?
Ich habe den langweiligsten TWF.
Den langweiligsten ETF.
TWF ist eine Ability in dem MMO, wo ich ja am Crimen bin.
Ich habe.
Was ist denn?
Vanguard FTSE All World ETF Accumulating.
Das langweiligste, was es gibt wahrscheinlich.
Aber das kann man ohne groß Hirn einfach regelmäßig was überweisen und laufen lassen.
Das, dass du mit Metaverse immer noch irgendjemand hinterm Ofen hervorbringst.
Da brauchst du, die brauchen ein neues Buzzword dafür.
Okay, lasst uns mal kurz gucken, was auf Shithub trendet.
Ich habe absolut keinen.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was es bedeuten soll.
Hier, lest euch das mal durch.
Modeling, Training, Eval & Inference Code for Olmo.
What?
Keine Ahnung.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Irgendein Finanzplaner.
AI.
Wie viele Note-Taking-Apps gibt es?
Wie viele Note-Taking-Apps gibt es denn bitteschön?
Die hat garantiert auch wieder keine Mobile-Apps und und.
Kein Notification Support.
Da gibt es tausende von diesen Apps.
OneNote suckt.
Und weißt du, warum OneNote suckt?
Weil OneNote keine Substring-Suche kann.
Du kannst den OneNote nur vom Anfang der Wörter her suchen.
Oder quasi ganze Wörter.
Das ist einfach nur abgrundtief schlecht.
Keine Ahnung, was mit Microsoft da los ist.
Das macht es komplett useless, finde ich.
Ich verstehe, warum es so ist.
Weil du Text-Index nicht gescheit machen kannst.
Mit Suchen von Wildcard von vorne.
Das klappt nicht gescheit.
Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich euch auch erklären, warum.
Aber dann musst du halt zu lineares Durchgreppen zurückfallen.
Wenn du nichts findest.
Kann man in ein Häkchen machen.
Aber das kann halt OneNote nicht.
Also, Chatgear, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Also mal angenommen, man könnte jetzt...
Oder was heißt mal angenommen?
Wir machen das einfach mit Crepe.
Also, ich stelle euch mal vor, ihr habt ein Notizprogramm mit ganz viel Text drinnen.
Und die indizieren das ja meistens.
Damit die Suche schneller geht.
Wenn du irgendwie hunderte Megabyte Text hast.
Und du willst da drinnen suchen.
Ist das ohne Index relativ...
Ja, lahm.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Warum kann ich in der Textdatei suchen.
Nach Cute Chat.
Oder nach...
Cute Chat.
Oder so.
Aber warum kann ich nicht.
Nach...
So suchen.
Wer ist High IQ.
Und will einen Sub verdienen.
Und weiß es.
Weil nichts mit einem Indexgeschalt funktioniert.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ob der IQ Boost schon gezogen hat.
Von den Prime Subs heute.
Also im Prinzip geht es.
Um das hier versus.
Warum das hier geht.
Meistens wenn es indiziert wurde.
Und das hier nicht.
Weil du die Tree von oben nach unten.
Und nicht von hinten nach...
String begins with.
Also generell.
Lineares Durchgreppen der Textdateien.
Ist kein Problem.
Dann funktioniert das.
Ich rede davon.
Wenn das indiziert ist.
Hängt mit SQL zusammen.
Nein.
Weil einfach random.
Have to write suche.
Nein.
Ich will wissen warum das so ist.
Also.
Der Chat weiß es nicht.
Cringe.
Also.
Es ist auch.
Wenn man sich damit nicht beschäftigt.
Es ist auch nicht gerade.
So soll man sagen.
Nicht gerade.
Obvious.
Warum das so ist.
Wir lassen mal alle Details.
Groß weg.
Wie sowas normalerweise.
In einem Index.
Gespeichert wird.
Bei Sortenlisten.
Ja.
Das geht in die richtige Richtung.
Sorted List.
Ist schon mal nicht.
Ist nicht falsch.
Ja.
Das in Kombination.
Ich muss sagen.
Der ECOS war bisher.
War bisher am.
Nächsten dran.
Also.
Wenn so.
Wenn sowas indiziert wird.
Dann wird das meistens.
Wir lassen.
Wie gesagt.
Mal alles.
Alles weg.
Ja.
Also.
Der E-Mail.
Ja.
Aber.
Wenn du.
Also.
Ein Index.
Sieht dann in der Regel.
So aus.
Wir machen das jetzt mal.
Ganz.
Ganz simpel.
Ja.
Also du indiziert.
Ganz viele.
Textdateien.
Und du bekommst.
Ein Index raus.
Ein Index.
Ist eine Kombination.
Aus.
Tokens.
Sagen wir mal Wörter.
Okay.
Und.
dazu gespeichert die position oder aber nur die datei je nachdem ob du nur
dateien finden willst oder die position ja du hast dann zum beispiel ein index
das sind dann wörter drin ja das sind da zum beispiel wörter drin wie lul oder
giga was auch immer chat und sowas in der richtung und dahinter steht dann so
was wie dieses wort befindet sich in das übrigens noch nicht richtig so wie
ich hier machen bevor jetzt gleich wieder irgendjemand sagt max so stimmt
das nicht dahinter befindet sich dann die geht es irgendwelche meter
informationen hast du dir dann dazu gespeichert zum beispiel keine ahnung
pfeiler und dort ist es dann position 230 also charakter charakter nummer 202
irgendwie 230 so oder und dann
wunderschön
lul wurde auch gefunden in fall b an position 4 und sowas und sowas speichert
sich das ganze allerdings speichert er sich das nicht so wie ich das hier
gemacht habe sondern das ganze wird sich sortiert gespeichert also c zuerst und
danach giga so und dahinter steht dann halt so dieser ganze andere krempe wieder
so in keine ahnung position 120 an position 1 8 800 oder so
ok
a salvation
so sieht
das dann aus und wenn du jetzt suchst in diesem index okay weil es sein wenn jetzt
suchst in diesem index dann suchst du nicht also mal angenommen besucht jetzt
nach nach allem was mit c anfängt so c sternchen dann ist das kein ding da kannst Parece Naples
Im Endeffekt, du halbierst die Liste immer wieder und guckst, ob du höher oder tiefer bist.
Wenn du zu hoch bist, dann nimmst du die nächste Hälfte, guckst bis zu hoch oder zu tief.
Bist du zu tief, nimmst du die obere Hälfte und so findest du relativ schnell in dem Index das, was du suchst.
Und Binary Search kannst du nur machen über sortierte Listen.
So und jetzt ist ja das Ding, es ist gar kein Problem zu suchen hier drinnen nach Sachen, die mit C anfangen.
Weil du musst halt den ersten Buchstaben suchen per Binary Search und dann ist gut.
Was du nicht machen kannst, ist nach Sternchen C suchen.
Weil wie willst du in dieser sortierten Liste Binary Search machen, wenn du den Anfang nicht kennst?
Die Dinger sind sortiert nach Anfangsbuchstaben.
Wenn du den Anfangsbuchstaben nicht kennst, kannst du kein Binary Search mehr machen.
Und dementsprechend funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Natürlich könntest du jetzt hergehen und den Index...
Den Index unnötig aufblähen.
Bubble Sort bringt dir auch nichts.
Weil es sind hier einzelne Wörter gespeichert.
Du musst tatsächlich linear suchen von Anfang bis Ende.
Weil du willst ja quasi...
Du musst jede Zeile durchsuchen.
Enthält das Wort ein C im Prinzip hierbei.
Das ist quasi lineare Suchen durch den kompletten Index durch.
Das würde funktionieren, das ist aber halt lahm as fuck.
Deswegen unterstützen das die meisten Suchen an der Stelle nicht.
Beziehungsweise nur mit einer Zulassung.
Eine Zusatzoption.
Du musst halt, dass du...
Ja, ich weiß, es ist jetzt besonders langsam.
Aber ich möchte bald gerade am Anfang machen.
Was du machen kannst ist...
Du könntest zum Beispiel hergehen.
Und das Ganze umdrehen.
Das machen auch manche.
Du kannst...
Also es gibt verschiedene...
Es gibt verschiedene...
Verfahren, das ein bisschen...
Ja, aufzulockern.
Also sprich, man versucht dann...
So quasi...
Rückwärts das Ganze zu speichern.
Damit man zum Beispiel dann von hinten suchen kann.
Oder man kann auch anfangen und einfach so das anders splitten oder sowas.
Oder man könnte sagen, ja, wir speichern einfach nur den Index von jedem Charakter.
Aber dann kannst du wieder keine Worte gescheit suchen, weil du dann die Position vergleichen musst.
Wenn du Worte suchst, kommt das eine nach dem anderen.
Also das ist ein super komplexes Gebiet.
Aber dadurch, dass das also Essenz aus dem Ganzen ist.
Dadurch, dass das in der sortierten Liste gespeichert wird.
Alphabetisch sortiert.
Kannst du nicht gescheit suchen in einem Index.
Mit Wildcard als ersten Buchstaben.
Es gibt übrigens noch einen weiteren.
Es gibt noch ein weiteres.
Doch, es gibt noch ein weiteres Verfahren.
Das ist ein bisschen aufwendiger vom Index her.
Das kann im Postgres zum Beispiel.
Das nennt sich Tree...
Tree Cram Search oder sowas.
Da werden Wörter immer in...
Dreierhäppchen...
Immer in Dreierhäppchen gespeichert.
Also da wird dann...
Aus Cute Chat wird dann...
Moment.
Kann das das überhaupt?
Also da kannst du...
Dann wird das aufgesplittet in drei.
Also Cute Chat wird beispielsweise gespeichert als Cute.
Als...
Nicht, dass ich das...
Als Ute.
Als Tech.
Und dann kannst du dich hier an den Substrings...
Dann kannst du Substring Search machen dadurch.
Also du kannst dann zum Beispiel sagen...
Ich suche jetzt den Substring.
Also damit kannst du dann sowas machen.
Wie ich suche...
Substring.te und sowas.
Das funktioniert dann.
Das haben wir hier im Stream mit Postgres auch schon mal probiert.
In OneNote funktioniert das gar nicht.
Das ist ja der Punkt da dran.
Das ist ja das, worauf ich rauswählen wollte.
OneNote hat keine Substring-Suche.
Und kann keine Wildcards am Anfang.
Was es für mich komplett useless macht als Notizprogramm.
Weil du oftmals, gerade wenn du dir irgendwelche Commandline-Sachen rauscopy-pastest,
nach Substrings suchen willst.
Und es wäre okay, würden die das Ganze indizieren zum schnellen Suchen.
Plus die Optionen bieten, da drüber zu kreppen, linear.
Machen sie aber nicht.
Deswegen ist OneNote aus meiner Sicht komplett useless.
Ein Notizprogramm ohne gescheite Suchfunktion ist für'n Arsch.
Und ja, super.
Was bringt mir Zusatzfeatures, wenn die most basic Sachen nicht funktionieren?
Und nachdem du dir OneNote auch nicht irgendwie mounten kannst unter Linux,
um da drin zu kreppen, meines Wissens nach,
ist es halt useless shit. Komplett für'n Arsch.
Kannst du null verwenden.
OneNote.
Also das ist auch noch ne Möglichkeit.
So kann man das auch machen.
Macht den Index natürlich deutlich größer.
Und hat glaube ich auch wieder andere Probleme,
wenn die Wörter zu lang werden.
Da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht mehr sicher.
Ah ja.
Das machst du mit Krepp, machst du das seit Jahrhunderten gefühlt.
Und das funktioniert.
Krepp ist ja auch jetzt nicht langsam.
Mein Krepp kackt natürlich ab, wenn es hier um Mega- und Gigabyte-große Textfiles geht.
Da wirst du ohne Index immer ein Problem haben.
Das Index erstellen dauert dann, aber das Suchen ist dann schnell.
Aber wenn's halt nicht anders geht, musst du halt linear drüberkreppen.
Und das kann OneNote nicht.
Das ist halt scheiße.
Ist halt richtig heutiger Dreck, das Programm dadurch.
Der Rest mag noch so cool sein, aber es ist einfach komplett unusable.
Durch dieses eine fehlende Feature.
Nein, haben wir noch nicht.
Können wir uns nachher angucken.
Wobei, doch haben wir uns angeguckt.
Letzte Woche oder vorletzte Woche, glaube ich.
Haben wir.
Der war eigentlich ganz cool, der E-Sport-Trainer.
Ich könnte wenden, Obsidian kann das.
Ich würde auch Obsidian verwenden, wenn Obsidian Notifications auf Mobile mit den Mobile-Apps unterstützen würde.
Das finde ich nämlich mega praktisch mit dem Notizprogramm, was ich aktuell verwende.
Ich kann eine Notiz machen und kann dann da reinschreiben.
Denk dran.
Denk dran, das bis Ende des Jahres oder so zu machen wegen der Steuererklärung.
So.
Und dann kriege ich dann irgendwie so ein Pop-Up auf Mobile hier.
Denk dran, das zu machen.
Es gibt kein Plugin für.
Weil Obsidian das auf Mobile nicht unterstützt.
Es gibt ein Reminder-Plugin für Obsidian, das funktioniert aber nicht auf Mobile.
Also wenn es das gäbe.
Guck, das hier gibt es.
Und wenn man hier nach Mobile sucht.
Send Notifications, blablabla.
Mobile.
Mobile Reminder.
Unfortunate is not possible right now.
Es gibt sogar ein Feature-Request.
Okay, der baut irgendwas dafür.
Ah.
Liste gibt es nicht.
Was halt ein bisschen suckt.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich ewig nicht benutzt.
Sieht aus wie 1995, ehrlich gesagt.
Mikrofokus.
Die kommen mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ich glaube bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Hatten wir das von denen.
Ist das nicht das, was Kobol in Java laufen lässt?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wollte ich mal kurz gucken.
Warte mal.
Mikrofokus.
Wie hieß dieser Compiler?
Boomerang.
Da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Der hing nämlich immer bei uns.
Da haben öfters mal irgendwelche Entwickler angerufen.
Und sich aufgeregt, dass es verbuggt wäre.
Ja, genau.
Akku Kobol.
Ja, den Mist hatten wir.
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Akku Kobol.
Und der Compiler von dem Ding nennt sich Boomerang.
Und der hängt öfters mal.
Und dann haben immer irgendwelche Entwickler angerufen.
Wahrscheinlich verwendet man das gar nicht mehr.
Das war noch, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe.
Nach der Ausbildung.
Für den Laden, wo ich danach dann weiter gewechselt bin hin.
Und da haben dann immer die Entwickler angerufen.
Oh, das hängt.
Was ist das denn?
Also als könnte ich was dafür, dass das Ding Schrott ist und hängt.
Akku Kobol.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich kann mich dran erinnern.
Siehste, da bist du richtig cool und hip, sobald du Akku Kobol verwendest.
Ist das C-Matrix auf dem iPhone, oder?
Das sah doch echt verdächtig aus nach nur auf dem iPhone.
Ja, und das Ganze natürlich in bunt.
Fand ihr nicht auch?
Ups.
Ich muss für meine Arbeit ein Projekt planen, das eine API mit Datenbank und Frontend-GUI
braucht, die die API an Frank schickt.
Ziemlich klassische Architektur.
Ich habe mich für C-Sharp entschieden.
Da hast du das schon mal richtig gemacht, weil ich damit angefangen habe zu programmieren.
Dafür passt es nicht.
Ich kenne mich aber mit dem ganzen .NET aus.
Was kannst du dafür empfehlen?
Hä?
Du meinst, ich kenne mich mit dem ganzen .NET-Zeug nicht aus?
Ich muss dafür gar nichts empfehlen.
Das ist alles Build-In.
Du legst ein ASP.NET Core-Projekt an und dann minimal APIs.
Das ist easy as fuck, was du machen willst.
Du sagst hier.
Pass mal auf.
Ich zeige euch jetzt sein Abschlussprojekt in drei Minuten.
Repos.
Warte hier.
Guck mal.
Temp.
mkdir.
lulw.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich gedacht, das gibt es schon.
So.
Jetzt sagst du .NET.
New.
Web.
Äh.
Was zum Teufel macht meine Konsole da gerade?
Dann öffnest du das Ganze in deiner IDE deiner Wahl.
Trust.
So.
Und dann hast du hier schon das Beispiel drinne.
Und das Slash.
So.
Und dann brauchst du jetzt dein API-Endpunkt.
Also ist ja hier schon.
Machst du hier Slash.
API.
Keckel.
Dann startest du das.
.NET.
Run.
Dann sagst du Curl.
Localhost.
Port.
Warum ist meine Konsole so im Arsch gerade?
59.
Slash.
Keckel.
Ups.
Not found.
Ah ne.
API.
Endpunkt.
Und zack.
Funktioniert.
Guck hier.
Easy.
Schon hast du dein API-Endpunkt.
API.
Slash.
Keckel.
Funktioniert.
Done.
Abgeben.
Gut.
Das Frontend.
Da musst du halt dir JavaScript-Zeug ausdenken.
Das ist jetzt ja wieder was anderes.
Das war es für API-Backend in C-Sharp.
Wer brauchst du da nicht für?
Ich meine, du musst natürlich Funktionalität reinbauen.
Aber das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
.NET ist quasi das komplette Ökosystem. Im Prinzip die Runtime, die Standardlibrary und ASP.NET, also quasi alle Standardkomponenten sind zusammengefasst in .NET. C-Sharp ist die Programmiersprache, ASP.NET Core ist ein Teil von .NET.
Es gibt ja noch andere Programmiersprachen auf .NET-Basis, wobei man sagen muss, C-Sharp ist mit Abstand die bekannteste und verbreitetste.
Ein paar Verrückte machen noch Visual Basic oder F-Sharp, aber das war's, mehr musst du nicht machen für deinen API-Backend.
Also zumindest für die Projektanlage.
Du willst für die GUI eine Desktop-Anwendung schreiben, du hast doch gerade gesagt Frontend.
Achso, mit Frontend.
Siehste mal, ich interpretiere.
Ich interpretiere hier schon automatisch JavaScript und Web-Gedöns rein.
Ja gut, kannst du auch.
Kannst du auch.
Du brauchst ein zweites Projekt.
Das läuft ja unabhängig voneinander.
Einen Server mit API-Backend und dann mach eine Windows Forms, das ist das simpelste, was es gibt.
Sieht zwar ein bisschen hässlich aus, aber Desktop-Programmierung in .NET generell unter Windows, das ist ja eigentlich Windows-Unterdienungs, aber auch.
Desktop-GUI-Programmierung ist Shit.
Deswegen gibt es so viele Elektron-Anwendungen.
Weil Desktop-GUI-Programmierung Shit ist.
Gibt es ja nicht wirklich viele gute Alternativen.
Maui ist halt komplett für den Arsch.
Dann würde ich tatsächlich Avalonia verwenden, wenn ich was Modernes haben will.
Avalonia ist mir tausendfach lieber als Maui.
Und selbst das geht mir auf den Keks, weil das immer noch XML-gefrickelt ist.
Qt finde ich eigentlich ganz nice, aber leider C++.
Ja, es gibt beinahe nichts zu anderen Sprachen, aber wirklich gut ist es auch nicht.
Was das angeht, da lernst du früher oder später immer bei C++.
Und ansonsten hast du noch ein bisschen neuere Sachen.
Die aber auf dem Desktop auch nicht so richtig gut integriert sind.
Du hast jetzt beispielsweise Flutter.
Flutter for Desktop.
Dann hast du halt im Prinzip das gleiche wie, also von der Optik her, hast du da irgendeine Elektron-Anwendung, die überall out of place aussieht.
Wobei das bestimmt besser geht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut Flutter on Desktop ist.
Das letzte Mal, als ich ausprobiert habe, war es so semi-gut.
Also man hat gemerkt, dass es eindeutig für Mobile-Optikern...
Außerdem ist es halt Flutter und Dart.
Was man sonst für nichts verwendet.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht das Beste.
Und Microsoft verkackt es ja seit Jahren, ihr eigenes Betriebssystem gescheit zu supporten.
Erst haben sie angefangen mit WPF.
Das war ja eine ganz gute Idee.
Nach Windows Forms haben sie angefangen mit WPF.
Das war ja eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee.
Leider auch hoffnungslos outdated mittlerweile und überholt.
Und auch viel zu kompliziert eigentlich für kleine Sachen.
Selbst für große.
WPF ist super bloated shit.
Danach kamen sie auf ihre chlorreichen Ideen mit...
WinRT und Javascript und Geschiss.
Und irgendwann kam dann UWP.
Und UWP ist es jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Jetzt gibt es WinUI 3.
Und WinUI 3 ist dann teilweise ansprechbar von Maui.
Aber Maui ist Cross-Plattform.
Linux nicht richtig unterstützt.
Malt Elemente nicht selbst.
Also ganz ehrlich, Avalonia ist wahrscheinlich das Beste, was du für halbwegs nicht komplett abgedrehte Desktop-App-Entwicklung zur Zeit machen kannst.
Oder ja...
Aber wenn dir C++ nichts ausmacht, ist Qt sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Deswegen haben wir so viele Elektron-Apps.
Weil easy und portable und sieht auch passabel aus.
Blazer...
Ich...
Ups, was hab ich da?
Jetzt hab ich irgendwas angeklickt.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Null.
Ähm...
Blazer mochte ich nie.
Aber ich glaube...
Ähm...
Gucken wir uns gleich an.
Aber ich glaube, Blazer ist mal wieder einen Blick wert.
Wir hatten es ja am Anfang des Streams, ne?
C++, das einfach absoluter Bullshit ist.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, ich sollte mir Blazer mal wieder angucken.
Ich war am Anfang übertrieben gehypt auf Blazer, weil ich mir dachte, nice, C-Sharp im Browser, aber letztendlich ganz ohne JavaScript für DOM-Interaktionen und sowas kommst du eh nicht aus.
Auch weil du im Browser irgendwann früher oder später auf das JavaScript-Ökosystem zurückgreifen musst und es auch gut ist, dass es so groß und vielfältig ist.
Und das zweite ist, was mich an Blazer abgeschreckt hat, dass du so lange brauchst zum Seitenladen.
Weil der erstmal irgendwie 8 MB, und das war noch relativ klein, 8 MB Mono-Runtime runterladen musste und dann initialisieren und starten.
Also das erste Laden war super langsam, sodass sich Blazer höchstens für irgendwelche internen, wo es sich auf die Geschwindigkeit ankommt, Anwendungen eignet.
Vielleicht muss ich mir das nochmal angucken.
Blazer ist nicht Blazer.
Blazing Lee ist nicht Blazer.
Blazing Lee Fast kann es schon mal nicht sein, weil es nicht written in Rust ist.
Wie wir ja wissen, Software wird, egal wie bescheuert, automatisch Blazing Lee Fast, dadurch dass es in Rust gewritten ist.
Dachte ich mir, dass es da Probleme gibt.
Yo Chat, gibt es eigentlich, was? Yo Chat, gibt es eigentlich, wenn man...
Was?
Yo Chat, gibt es eigentlich...
Kann ich nicht lesen, ja.
Gibt es eigentlich, wenn man K3S oder K8S auf Heads nachhausten will?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Was hast du gegen den normalen Autoscaler, den offiziellen Kubernetes Autoscaler?
Achso, du meinst, dass der automatisch Nodes erstellt und sowas.
Jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst.
Dass der automatisch...
Dass du quasi einen Node-Pool hast, der von, keine Ahnung, mindestens 3 Nodes bis auf 20 hochskaliert und sowas.
Meinst du sowas?
Dann weiß, dann fällt mir da für Heads nach keiner ein.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe auf Heads nach auch noch kein Kubernetes bisher laufen lassen.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass der offizielle Autoscaler das bei Heads nach so out of the box kann.
Ehrlich gesagt, das ist...
Also ich habe an Autoscaler jetzt erstmal nur an Pods skalieren gedacht, aber nee, nee, nee, du meinst den Node-Pool skalieren.
Ehrlich gesagt, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das
ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist,
Not safe for work?
Alter!
What the fuck, man!
Reddit, please!
Sei doch nicht so eine Dreckseide, man!
Es kann doch...
Es ist doch unmöglich, oder?
Es kann doch nicht sein!
Ich darf es speichern, oder?
Äh...
Fotos, mir doch egal, ne?
So.
Okay.
Moment, das ist aber nur das Preview.
Das ist nicht das Bild in voller Auflösung.
Was ich jetzt gespeichert habe.
Nochmal Bild speichern unter.
Jetzt ist es auch ein PNG.
Okay.
Wir sind schon falsch abgebogen, Webdesign-technisch, oder?
Jetzt.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Das ist doch echt nicht mehr normal, man.
Okay.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Windows 95 Win32.
Ja, das ist der alte Audio-Dialog.
Weiß ich, gibt es den?
Wie?
Gibt es noch, oder?
Irgendwo gibt es den alten Audio-Dialog noch, oder?
Oder ist der jetzt komplett weg?
Da muss ich bestimmt den Control-Panel...
Sound...
Ah, yes!
Okay, also Windows 95 Win32.
NTP 4 haben wir auch noch.
Nicht NTP, Alter.
NTP 4.
Aber schon moderner aus als NTP 4.
Windows XP, ja.
Control-Panel und Geschiss.
Windows Store...
Ja, gut.
Lost.
Dieses hässliche Site-Ding.
Äh, Windows 10 Fluent.
Windows 10 Modern?
Es ist so lächerlich.
Windows 11 Sun...
Ach, Moment!
Wait a minute.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Fluent Design ist out?
Weil der Calculator ist immer noch Fluent Design.
Ich dachte, das ist immer noch angesagt jetzt.
Ist es, ist es wieder was Neues, oder wie?
Ich fand den Ansatz mit Fluent Design ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so schlecht.
Anscheinend ist das jetzt aber out.
Okay.
Windows 7 Ribbon...
Ribbons!
Ja, Ribbon-UI und, und Vista Aero.
Äh, und, und, was wir auch noch haben.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich zeig das immer ganz gerne.
Das haben wir auch noch.
Ich glaub, das ist, das ist straight aus Windows 3.11.
Oder Windows 95, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich Windows 95.
Es sieht zu modern aus für Windows 3.11.
Da ist tatsächlich, da ist, ohne Scheiß, da ist es tatsächlich unter Linux besser.
Weil unter Linux sind die Sachen halt...
...meistens entweder Oldschool GTK 2 Look, irgendein etwas modernerer GTK 3, 4, 5, 7, 8, 9, was auch immer, wo die grad sind, Top 4 Look, Cute Look mit 30 Milliarden Skins oder selbstgebastelter Kram.
Aber es ist nicht ganz so wild wie unter Windows.
Das stimmt.
Was das hier ist, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist bestimmt Windows 95.
Wobei dieses Icon-Ding könnte tatsächlich...
...auch Windows 3.11 sein.
Alter.
Ach ja, und by the way, diese komische Leiste hier neben.
Gibt es irgendjemanden auf der Welt, der die benutzt?
Das ist für mich so most, most useless...
...Feature von Windows.
Aber wobei, wobei nein.
Most useless Feature ist Widgets.
Die aus, wo ich gar nicht mal weiß, wie ich die, hups.
Wo überhaupt nicht mal weiß, wie ich die überhaupt aufmache.
Es gibt da, gibt da so Inti, Integrated Widgets.
Die verwendet aber auch niemand.
Windows W ist...
Shit.
Da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
Ach stimmt, ja, in Berlin haben sie es ja mit Wählen noch nicht mal hingekriegt.
Berlin ist echt auch richtig lost, was das angeht.
Ich verstehe nie, warum alle C++ hassen.
Irgendwie schwebt da immer ein, es ist mir zu verwirrend, akrat zu schwer mit...
Naja, das ist ja schon mal ein guter Punkt, ohne dass es zu verwirrend ist.
Aber Anfang des Streams habe ich noch einen Punkt gezeigt, was eindeutig dafür spricht, dass C++ einfach nur Schrott ist.
Weiß nicht, ob du da schon da gewesen bist.
Es war ziemlich...
Ich bin nicht am Anfang des Streams.
Ich will jetzt nicht nochmal davon anfangen, weil wenn ich jetzt nochmal damit anfange, dann...
Machen wir heute gar nichts mehr außer C++ Rant.
Ich weiß.
Auch in Frankfurt, Chainlaw?
Oh fuck, der Chainlaw ist gar nicht so weit weg, wie ich dachte.
Wenn ich demnächst einen sehe, der irgendwo gebannt wird, weiß ich, das muss der Chainlaw sein.
Hausverbot beim Rewe.
Weißt du Bescheid.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das Aufbauen von Nodes.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert bei was anderem als Google und Azure.
Und da funktioniert es halt ohne Probleme, weil das integriert ist und da Millionen draufschmeißen.
Weißt du, das ist echt eine gute Frage.
Kubernetes Autoscaler Hetzner.
Was da irgendwas gibt?
Okay.
Das ist im offiziellen Kubernetes Autoscaler sogar mit drin?
Krass.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Guck mal hier.
Hetzner ist dabei.
Hey.
Ansonsten.
Von den deutschen anderen Hoster keiner.
Guck mal.
Nur Hetzner am Start.
Die machen doch schon was richtig.
Hast AliExpress, AliCloud, AWS, Azure, Baidu Cloud.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Baidu Cloud und AliCloud was unterschiedlich sind.
Bis FlyCloud und EGOT, Brightbox, Cherry Servers, CloudStack, Cluster, AP Digital Ocean, KlarE,
Winix, Metal, die Extrascale, Google, Hetzner.
Wie, wie, wei, wei, wei, Cloud, IONOS, okay, wir sind am Start, nie gehört, aber, ach doch, OVH ist auch dabei, guck mal, OVH ist auch am Start, aber nice, dass der Hetzner dabei ist, das ist doch mega.
Dann sollte das doch gut funktionieren mit dem Scalen.
Nice.
Pogu.
Oh nein, Bot gespammt.
Why?
What is your opinion?
What is your opinion about Web3 and Blockchain?
I'm happy that all the NFT shit is gone away.
Ja, na gut, aber wenn er es braucht, es ist interessant zu wissen, dass das bei Hetzner in dem Standard Kubernetes Autoscaler alles drin ist, das wusste ich nicht.
Das ist aber nice.
Suche schon eine Wohnung in Offenbach, Beste.
Ich hab kein, Control, Shift, Alt, Win, Plus, ist das jetzt den in Ernst?
Wer soll das drücken?
Also bei Google gibt es ein nice Feature, dass man bei Datenbanken den Platz, den Speicherplatz on the fly automatisch erweitern kann, wenn es zu voll ist.
Natürlich, wenn du nicht aufpasst, kann das teuer werden.
DB Scalen ist tatsächlich gar nicht so, gar nicht so einfach.
DB Scalen ist Six Head, Six Head Architektur.
Also wenn es klassische Sachen sind, wie Postgres oder so, das ist echt nicht so trivial mit Scalen und hochverfügbarem Setup und sowas.
Und selbst eine Cloud SQL Instance bei Google ist jetzt nicht so einfach.
Die ist halt einfach eine Managed Datenbank.
So einfach skaliert ist die auch nicht.
Ich mein, du kannst fette Kisten dann hinstellen und sowas.
Aber, ja, Datenbank skalieren ist echt so eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Okay, wir sind immer noch bei den, immer noch nach einer Stunde, bei den Trending Sachen.
So, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
Seaweed FS.
Moment.
20.000 Stunden.
20.000 Sterne, was ist das?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Seaweed FS is a fast distributed storage system for blobs, object files and data lake.
Or billions of files.
Ist das sowas wie Ceph oder sowas?
Blobstore has O1-Disk-Seq-Cloud-Tiering-File-Google-Drive-Cross-DC-Acto-What-the-Massive-Six-Head-Kram.
Bestimmt written in Go, weil, weil Go.
Ja, ja, ja, natürlich.
Was sonst?
Oder?
Written in Go.
Ich meine, written in Go ist nicht mal so angesagt.
Written in Rust ist heutzutage angesagt.
Aber written in Go ist auch noch, auch noch semi-cool, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es jetzt genau ist und macht.
Aber, ja, nice Kram.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
NetOS, NetBox.
Ist das nicht so ein IP-Management-System?
Das nennt sich anscheinend jetzt nicht mehr IP-Management, das nennt sich jetzt The Premier Source of Truth.
The Premier Source of Truth Powering Network Automation.
IP-Adress-Management ist zu, ja, low IQ der Name.
Aber es ist letztendlich ein IP-Adress-Management-Tool.
Warum man ein IP-Management, warum man nicht IP-Adress-Management reinschreiben kann, weiß ich nicht.
Es ist eine Premier Source of Truth Powering Network Automation.
Ja, glaube ich dir.
J-Lord, das Video muss ich nicht anklicken, dass ich weiß, dass das garantiert nicht du bei der Bank ist.
Bist du Kaffee-Enjoyer? Ne.
Das verwirrt die Franzosen immer. Ich spiele ab und zu MMOs mit Franzosen.
Und die denken immer, weil ich German bin, müsste ich den ganzen Tag Bier trinken.
Und ich sage denen immer, ich trinke kein Bier.
Und ich arbeite in der IT und trinke keinen Kaffee. Das sind schon zwei Sachen, die nicht zusammenpassen, ne.
Sass.
Very sass.
Ne, der hat Bier getrunken und hat gemeint, wie das bei mir aussieht, weil ich bin doch German.
Ich würde doch jetzt bestimmt auch gerade Bier trinken.
Und du sagst, ne, nur weil du German bist, musst du nicht automatisch den ganzen Tag Bier trinken.
Aber es ist echt schlimm, wenn du mit Franzosen im Discord, ich wollte gerade sagen Teamspeak, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht, das hat sich irgendwie so verhärtet in meinem Kopf, dass man Voice Communication Teamspeak nennt.
Wenn du mit Franzosen öfters im Discord bist.
Und die schaffen es bei manchen Wörtern eben nicht, das H davor auszusprechen.
Und das Schlimme ist, ich fange mit diesem Mist auch schon teilweise an.
Ja, die sagen, es gibt beispielsweise, es gibt ein Wort in dem MMO, was ich spiele, das nennt sich Hips.
Hat nichts mit Hüfte zu tun.
Ja, Hips.
Und die Franzosen können das nicht. Die sagen Ibs.
Und ich fange jetzt teilweise auch schon an, Ibs zu sagen, anstatt Hips.
Es ist schlimm, wenn du den ganzen Tag nichts anderes hörst.
Dann fängst du auch mit dem Kram an.
Ja.
Ich finde das, ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, ich finde das gar nicht schlimm, wenn die da so ein bisschen Vorurteile haben.
Sollen sie machen.
Mein Vorurteil ist ja heute ganz super, super dramatisch.
Theoretisch müsste ich jetzt sagen, oh, alles krasse Rassisten, Alter.
Die kommen hier gleich und denken, ich habe eine Lederhose an.
Ja, das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Mich juckt das, mich juckt das null, ob die denken, dass ich Lederhose an, ob ich die Lederhose an habe.
Sag ich denen halt im Zweifelsfall.
Nee, wir rennen nicht nur mit Lederhose rum.
Ja.
Ganz ehrlich, es ist super angenehm mit den Franzosen zu kreiselkreiten.
Ach stimmt, habe ich ganz vergessen.
Ja, hast ja recht, hast ja recht.
Es funktioniert ja eh nicht.
Ja, ja.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Ich weiß auch, warum ich kaum noch sowas...
Oh, guck mal.
Moment, ich kriege mein eigenes Wort empfohlen.
Was ist denn da los?
Wer macht denn die Captions hier unten?
Wer macht sich Mühe?
Ist das AI generated?
Moment, los geht's.
Ist auch witzig, ne?
Von 55 Minuten bis...
Also, wir haben quasi knapp 1 Stunde 45 das eigentliche Thema gemacht.
Davor war random Geschwätze.
Und danach waren tatsächlich...
Noch...
Wie lang?
Noch 2 Stunden random Geschwätze.
Also, wir haben quasi das Stream-Thema 1 Stunde 45 versus...
Drei Stunden random Geschwätze.
Normaler Stream, oder?
Normaler Stream.
Ja.
Ähm, Jano, du meinst das Video, gell?
Wie das jetzt einfach empfohlen wird.
Manchmal habe ich echt das Gefühl, Google liest mit...
Zweiter Stream?
Weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Wir müssen erst mal an dem Command Line Tool weiter basteln.
Eigentlich hatte ich das ja vor, heute zu machen, aber...
Mal gucken, wie der Kreisel-Crime aussieht.
Oh, wir müssen uns auch noch die Stellenanzeigen fertig angucken.
Immer fertig.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und wenn ich zu Ende komme...
Moment...
Ist das...
Ist das Clash of Clans Cheating Dings oder was ist das?
Ne.
Es ist...
Ne, es ist was anderes.
Dachte erst mal...
Man weiß ja nie.
Express-Trended, was ist denn da los?
Express ist ja voll outdated, overrated, cheap-baited.
Redet heute keiner mehr drüber.
Obwohl ganz viele Websachen im Backend noch mit Express laufen.
Haben wir Express-Enjoyers im Chat?
Ich habe noch nie Express verwendet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich will auch nicht.
Wieso sollte Express outdated sein?
Nee, mit outdated, overrated, cheap-baited meine ich,
das ist so ein Ding, wo keiner mehr drüber redet.
Und nicht, dass es keiner mehr verwendet.
Ansible-Trended auch.
Ansible ist nice.
Hyperland, ja, würde ich gerne ausprobieren.
Problem ist, geht in der VM nicht richtig.
AI, Fast API.
Tippst.
Was in New Markup-Based Type-Setting-Systeme ist Powerful?
Okay, das ist, oh.
Nicht mal.
Nicht mal Latex, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Das ist jetzt was Neues.
Tippst.
Written in Rust.
Was das für epische Musik ist.
Das ist.
Das ist der former World of Goo und das ist Kirby Planet Robobot.
Welche Game-Musik.
Die Frage ist jetzt, ist das wirklich so viel besser?
Oder ist das ein weiteres Ding der Kategorie,
die Rust-Community löst Probleme,
die nicht existieren?
Das ist die Frage.
Das frage ich mich bei Rust-Projekten immer.
Genauso wie die 20 LS-Rewrites und sowas.
Dann kann jeder mit seiner Freizeit machen, was er will.
Und zum Üben sicherlich nice, die ganzen Rust-Projekte.
Die ganzen 1000 Rewrites.
Ah, das Written in Rust.
25, 26 K-Sterne.
Es gab ja letztens welche,
die auf Reddit wieder angefangen haben,
dass C-Sharp und .NET sind totlos.
Und wisst ihr warum?
Weil Microsoft einen Rust-Entwickler sucht.
Den Bogen musste er erst mal spannen.
Von der Stich-, von der
Wir suchen einen Rust-Entwickler zu .NET ist tot.
Das ist schon echt
sehr fantasievoll.
Was glaubst du, welche Sprache wird
in den nächsten 5 Jahren am meisten an Bedeutung gewinnen?
Rust wird auf jeden Fall weiter gehypt werden,
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaube aber auch, C-Sharp wird sich immer weiter durchsetzen.
In mehreren Bereichen.
Die Sprache hat die letzten Jahre über
schon ordentlich Aufwind gehabt.
Und bei vielen Sachen hat sich jetzt ja auch durchgesprochen,
dass .NET Core bzw. einfach nur noch .NET
mittlerweile kein
Windows-only Shit mehr ist,
mit dem man nur noch Windows-Guys machen kann.
C-Sharp ist eine super Sprache, .NET ist eine super Runtime
und das Standard-Library und das Framework
ist auch nice.
Also ich glaube, dass sich
.NET und C-Sharp wirklich
weiterhin durchsetzen werden, etablieren werden.
Auch in Bereichen außerhalb von
Business Enterprise Krempel.
Rust auf jeden Fall.
Javascript wird uns erhalten bleiben.
Javascript wird
werden wir nie wieder los.
Was ich auch gar nicht schlimm finde,
weil Javascript mittlerweile
echt ganz gute Sprache geworden ist.
Nicht so wie in C++.
C++ hat sich ja gefühlt mit den neuesten Standards
ich will nicht sagen zurückentwickelt,
weil es auch viele neue coole Sachen gab,
aber das Windows,
das C++, Windows, ja Windows auch,
aber das C++ Gremium baut einfach nur
einen Mist nach dem anderen.
Ja, und
die Javascript-Leute machen sinnvolle
Dinger. Also Javascript bleibt auf jeden Fall erhalten.
Und ansonsten
so irgendwie super krasse Newcomer-Sprachen
fällt mir schwer
zu predikten. Also ich glaube
nicht, dass es was sein wird von den
Dingern, die so semi-beliebt
sind. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das SICK
oder so jetzt voll durch die Decke gehen wird
oder sowas.
Aber auch nicht, dass Julia oder solche
Sachen voll durch die Ecke gehen würde.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich glaube in fünf Jahren sieht das nicht so
viel anders aus als heute,
was Programmiersprachen angeht.
Mit den zwei Sachen, also
plus die drei Sachen, die ich jetzt halt
gesagt habe. Ich denke, die werden wir sehen.
Ansonsten wird nicht so viel
Unterschied sein zu heute.
Welche Programmiersprache ist die beste?
Du musst immer fragen, wofür?
Wofür die beste?
Das kann man nicht pauschal beantworten.
Das ist die
Antwort fürs Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das ist das, wo ihr
dann sagen könnt, hier guckt mal,
ich bin voll
Senior Developer
Fifed.
Und dann kannst du das ganze noch mit ein paar
Business Terms anreichern, wenn du es
voll übertreiben willst.
Weil ich meine, du willst ja auch eindeutig die besten
Values createn. Ist so.
Manchmal hast du ja gar keine andere Wahl.
Weil es,
soweit es so richtig in einer Sprache geht,
manchmal bietet es sich einfach an, weil
es super viele
fertige Sachen für eine bestimmte Sprache
gibt. Und oftmals ist es so,
dass man sich tatsächlich für das entscheidet,
was einem persönlich am liebsten ist, weil man da
beispielsweise die meiste Erfahrung mit drin hat.
Und damit fährt man ja
in der Regel auch gut.
Zum Einstieg, meiner Meinung nach
eindeutig JavaScript. Ich weiß, viele
sagen Python und sowas, manche verrückten
Leute sagen auch C, habe ich schon gehört.
Aber da bin ich anderer Meinung
gewesen.
Ich finde tatsächlich JavaScript zum
Einstieg am besten.
Kann auch mit Python und Go
anfangen.
Aber JavaScript
ist mega nice zum Einstieg,
weil es so eine niedrige Hürde hat.
Visual Studio Code installiert,
fertig, mehr brauchst
du nicht. Du brauchst kein Node,
du brauchst nix, du brauchst einfach nur einen Browser.
Genau. Also JavaScript
finde ich ist deswegen zum Einstieg am besten.
Danach, das Problem bei
JavaScript ist, der Einstieg ist am
einfachsten, aber
die Ökosystem Lernkurve
ist am größten Abfuck
in JavaScript. Das ist
echt tückisch so. Ein bisschen wie bei Kubernetes.
Du denkst auch am Anfang relativ schnell, du hast
verstanden und dann checkst du erstmal, was du
alles an Ökosystem noch drum
herum lernen musst.
Bei JavaScript ist es so,
easy Einstieg, Text Editor, Browser
funktioniert wunderbar, aber dann geht's los.
Dann geht's los. Irgendwann
installierst du dir Node, weil du vielleicht beispielsweise
irgendein Frontend Framework verwenden willst,
dann brauchst du,
musst du das ganze bundeln, packagen,
npm installen,
das halbe Internet und dann
funktioniert irgendwas nicht. Dann brauchst du,
ich mein so ein JavaScript Projekt, wenn du das Scav
holdest mit irgendeinem CLI Tool, hat
keine Ahnung, 18 Config Files
standardmäßig schon drin, damit es überhaupt ein sinnvolles
Default Behavior
hat so.
Echt, echt wir.
Ne, zum Einstieg würde ich kein TypeScript nehmen.
Einstieg würde ich plain JavaScript.
Ja, also
das ist halt das Ding bei JavaScript,
das ist halt super wir.
Kann sich noch jemand an Webpack erinnern?
Gibt es Webpack
Enjoyer, die das wirklich mögen?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand Webpack
mag. Manche müssen
noch teilweise Webpack verwenden,
aber Webpack war somit das schrecklichste, was
es gab. Darfst das noch
täglich nutzen? Oh je.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin nicht so im
React Game.
PHP 7 in der Berufsschule?
Ja, warum nicht? Ich mein, PHP ist
durchaus
brauchbar, wenn auch
äußerst wir
an manchen Stellen. Aber es ist
konsistenter als C++.
Ja gut, das mag sein.
Das mag sein, ja. Das Schöne ist, dass
du an Vite kaum was konfigurieren musst.
Zum aktuellen Umschulungshype.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es
einen Umschulungshype gibt.
Wusstet ihr das Chat, dass es einen
Umschulungshype gibt?
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht stimmt.
Das kann durchaus sein.
War mir aber nicht ganz klar, dass es einen
Umschulungshype gibt.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich null
mit beschäftigt bisher.
Wundert mich aber nicht,
weil hier alle händeringend Leute suchen.
Ob jemand in drei Monaten zu einem
ordentlichen Entwickler wird,
wenn er vorher damit nichts am Hut hat,
wage ich mal ganz stark zu bezweifeln.
Wenn du jemanden hast, der vielleicht
früher
in der IT tätig war und
sich schon immer für Programmieren
interessiert hat, aber halt quasi
noch keine größere Erfahrung
wie es so ist im Team Software zu
entwickeln oder vielleicht
keine Ahnung jetzt
nicht so die
aktuellen Tools da kennt.
Das kriegst du in drei Monaten hin,
wenn der halt schon Vorkenntnisse hat und Ahnung
und eigentlich Programmieren kann.
Bringst du das keinem ordentlich bei?
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist schon grenzwertig,
geb ich dir recht.
Wobei so schlimm kann es nicht sein, Chainlore.
Wir nehmen dich ja
hier im Stream auch.
Du bist ja auch nicht gebannt.
Wie aufgefühlt irgendwie.
Was hast du mal erzählt?
Ja.
Irgendwie fünfter Bann in Discord oder sowas.
Ich kann mir aber schon
manchmal denken, warum
bei Sempervideos bist du gebannt.
Auch. Wie hast
du das geschafft?
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
ASCII Spam, ja das wundert
mich nicht.
Aber das stimmt.
Aber das Ding ist
auch ein bisschen, dass viele händeringend
erfahrene Leute suchen, aber
keinen Bock haben auszubilden.
Was ich ja irgendwie beiß. Du kannst nicht nur
erfahrene Leute suchen, aber
nicht mit dafür sorgen, dass
erfahrene Leute nachkommen.
Für mich
ist das alles top.
Ich kann fett Kohle kassieren
und hab
selbst wenn ich keinen Bock auf den aktuellen
Job hab, in
2 Minuten 30
5 neue Angebote.
Wo ich mir irgendwas raussuchen kann.
Also für mich ist das gut.
Aber insgesamt
ist es kacke.
Heise Kommentare, das kann ich mir, das gebe ich mir
manchmal im Zug.
Aber da darf man nicht zu viele
Hoffnungen haben, wenn man die Kommentarsektion
in Heise aufmacht.
Bei Golem ist es minimal besser, weil
bei Golem kommentieren weniger Leute.
Hattest du nicht damals auch ein Problem
einen guten neuen Job zu finden?
Ja, ganz damals hatte ich richtig Probleme.
Aber ganz damals war noch vor meiner
Ausbildung, also das war dann irgendwann
wo ich den
Arbeitsamtkurs machen musste irgendwie.
Frag mich nicht, 2002
oder so, das ist schon ein bisschen her.
So 22 Jahre ist das her.
Oder was meinst du jetzt?
Ja, damals hatten wir, damals
war deutlich höhere Arbeitslosigkeit
als heute.
Und die hatten damals
alle noch so komische Vorstellungen,
dass IT-Jobs nur
gemacht werden können von Leuten mit
super krassem Abi und sowas.
Was halt Schwachsinn ist. Hätte man
damals mal ein bisschen auf
Nachwuchsförderung gesetzt oder beziehungsweise
generell auf Fachkräfteausbildung gesetzt, dann hätten wir
jetzt auch mehr. Vielleicht gab es aber einfach,
na wobei doch, ich weiß noch, ich hab mich, ich hab
mich damals auch beworben bei
so einem Laden
hier. Das war super weird.
Da habe ich damals diesen,
der ist ja mittlerweile berühmt, berüchtigt,
dieser Test. Da gibt's,
habt ihr vielleicht auch schon davon
gehört, also so
Einstellungs, wie nennt
man das so, Assessment Center oder so Einstellungstest.
Und zwar bekommt ihr da eine
Liste mit 20 Punkten oder 10 Punkten,
ist egal, das ist eine Liste mit vielen Punkten drauf.
Und auf dem ersten Punkt
steht dann so irgendwie
erstens
lesen Sie sich alles in Ruhe durch,
bevor Sie anfangen. Zweitens
erstellen Sie eine Liste mit Ihren Hobbys.
Drittens gehen Sie
einmal aufs Klo. Viertens rennen Sie
einmal um den Stuhl. Es wird immer abgedrehter.
Und bei Punkt 20 steht
dann
unterschreiben Sie das hier und geben
Sie es ab.
Ohne die Punkte durchzuführen, die oben drüber
stehen. Das ist der
aus meiner Sicht der
dümmste und
der dümmste Test und ich habe
keine Ahnung, was der irgendwie belegen soll.
Soll das belegen?
Egal wie unsinnig die
Anweisung ist, man
führt sie aus, weil
es geht entgegen jeglicher Erfahrung,
die man bisher im Leben gemacht hat.
Was in der Regel
kein gutes Zeichen ist.
Wann besteht den Test? Ahja, wenn man
einen Zettel abgibt, ohne was gemacht zu haben.
Ähm, gebe ich dir recht,
aber die können ja ruhig den
Eindruck vermitteln, das ist nicht,
das ist ja nicht so.
Die labern viel, wenn der Tag
lang ist, das ist ja nicht so. Die tun halt
so und eventuell stellen
die auch ein paar Leute damit ein und weißt
du warum? Weil sie verzweifelt sind.
Die finden nichts anderes.
Denen bleibt gar nichts anderes da übrig.
Die stellen auch irgendwelche ehemaligen Mathelehrer
ein, die vor 15 Jahren
Pascal programmiert haben.
Weil die so verzweifelt sind.
Mit Leute finden.
Und ja, es gibt einen
Fachkräftemangel.
Der ist aber bei weitem nicht so krass, wie
er immer gemacht wird von irgendwelchen
Interessensvertretungsverbänden.
Weil ein Fachkräftemangel,
also wenn man sich die Arbeitsamtsstatistik
anguckt, bedeutet ja nur,
dass Stellen eine gewisse Zeit offen
bleiben und nicht besetzt werden können. Also
sobald Stellen nicht besetzt werden können, ist es
ein Fachkräftemangel. Warum diese
Stellen nicht besetzt werden können, ist halt
die Frage. Und bei den
meisten Stellen liegt es wahrscheinlich daran,
weil der Arbeitgeber Schrott ist.
Und die Leute da keinen Bock drauf haben.
Oder halt.
Das Angebot Schrott ist aus unterschiedlichsten
Gründen.
Laden taucht nix. Suchst nach dem Laden,
findest irgendwie erstmal 50 Sachen, warum du da auf
keinen Fall hin willst.
Laden ist Schrott.
Vielleicht sind sie gut, vielleicht schaffen sie es
sich nicht attraktiv zu verkaufen.
Gehalt ist Kacke.
Die Stellenanzeigen
sind oftmals auch absoluter Bullshit.
Wir haben uns ja auch schon Stellenanzeigen angeguckt,
wo ich mir denke, was ist mit euch los, Mann?
Wer hat denn das wieder geschrieben?
Die vergessen oftmals,
die Stellenanzeige
ist quasi wie eine Bewerbung.
Das ist der erste Eindruck, den du
von dem Unternehmen kriegst.
Genauso wie dein Anschreiben und deine Bewerbung.
Das ist der erste Eindruck, den die von dir kriegen.
Aber erstmal
mussten die
soweit guten Eindruck machen, dass du dich überhaupt
dort bewirbst.
Die Stellenanzeige sieht teilweise so aus,
wie die Dinger, die wir uns hier angucken.
Wo dann irgendwie sowas ist.
Ach ja, und übrigens machst du auch noch Projektleitung
und kümmerst dich um die kleinen PCs
aller anderen Mitarbeiter.
So unten drunter, so erwähnt, by the way,
auch übrigens.
Dann denken sich die Leute halt, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Dann fange ich das gar nicht an.
Und dann heulen sie rum, Fachkräftemangel.
Fachkräftemangel, was?
Warum?
Wenn sich der Chef bei dir bewirbt.
Ja.
Ist das, ist das der?
Mit dem
Senior Pearl Expert
Programmer und sowas?
Ja. Muss ich ehrlich sagen,
paar Sachen waren ganz lustig,
aber zum größten Teil
geht's
irgendwie an mir vorbei.
Ja, der hat ein paar gute Sachen, aber das meiste muss ich sagen,
find ich jetzt nicht so lustig.
Ja, ja und nein, man muss
sagen, die haben auch Probleme.
Also ohne Probleme würde
ich nicht sagen.
Ich finde, der Laden, wo ich jetzt gelandet bin,
ist echt nicht schlecht.
Sowohl von Arbeitsbedingungen her, von der
Homeoffice Regelung her, von den Homeoffice
Möglichkeiten her, vom Gehalt,
so generell
Umgang mit den Leuten, ich kann mich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Sicherlich ist das nicht
das geilste Ever, wovon ich
immer geträumt habe, dafür ist das viel zu
bürokratisch und nervig an vielen
Stellen, aber die Gesamtkombination ist
wirklich okay.
So okay, dass ich
nicht sagen würde, oh ja, ich
guck jetzt hier nebenbei Stellenanzeigen
an. Wenn ich mir Stellenanzeigen angucke, dann meistens
hier nur just for fun, für den Stream und nix, was
ich wirklich machen will. Also
ich hab vor, da auf absehbarer Zeit
zu bleiben.
Und die hatten richtig Probleme, Leute
zu finden. Also ich glaube, meine
Stelle war ein dreiviertel Jahr offen, da hat sich
keiner drauf beworben. Die Stellenanzeige
war aber auch kacke,
wo wir wieder dabei sind. Die Stellenanzeige war
richtig mies. Ich hätte mich da nicht drauf
beworben, hätte mich nicht ein ehemaliger
Kollege angeschrieben und gesagt, hier Max,
ich hab gehört, du suchst was
Neues, wir haben was.
Aber die Stellenanzeige ist kacke, der Laden
ist gut.
Und
der Laden taugt
auch wirklich. Aber anhand der Stellenanzeige
hätte das nicht geklappt. Also die haben auch Probleme, ja.
Die haben richtig Probleme, was zu finden.
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Lass das mal kurz gucken.
Bin immer noch verwirrt, weil ich zu viele
...
Oh, Foto vom Opa?
Ich weiß ja nicht, Alter.
Comic Sans.
Tischkicker Obstkorb.
Okay, das ist G-Bait.
Die veräppeln uns hier, oder?
Ist das dein Ernst?
Das ist doch Verarschung.
Das haben die geschrieben für den Beitrag nur, oder?
...genug, denn in Deutschland herrscht Fachkräftemangel.
Daher hat der potenzielle Arbeitgeber
zum Bewerbungsgespräch eingeladen.
Einen schönen guten Tag.
Michael Lüretz, mein Name.
Ich komme wegen des Bewerbungsgesprächs.
Ja, setzen Sie sich bitte.
Moment, ist das...
So, Herr Müritz.
Sie möchten also, dass ich bei Ihnen meine Ausbildung mache?
Ja, ja.
Es ist mir jetzt auch aufgefallen,
dass das Verarschung ist.
Warum möchten Sie denn mein Arbeitgeber werden?
Was haben Sie denn so vorzuweisen?
Naja, also unter Obstkorb geht schon mal nix.
Ich will den Job unbedingt.
Also, für mich...
Für Lukas.
Aber die Konkurrenz, um Junge auszubilden, ist groß.
Ist das echt so?
Wer sich im harten Ausbildungsmarkt durchsetzen will,
muss sich anstrengen.
Die meisten wollen ja nicht ausbilden,
die wollen irgendwelche Leute mit Erfahrung haben.
Oh ne, ich glaube, das ist unlustig.
Ist mir zu cringe.
Das verdient ein Kubernetes-Admin in Deutschland.
Okay, Moment.
Ein Kubernetes-Admin in Deutschland.
Ist das AI?
Ist das AI-Text?
Leute, ist das AI-Text?
Passt mal auf.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Job Radio Deutschland
zu unserem heutigen Video.
Heute sprechen wir über das Berufsbild des Plattform-Ingenieurs
mit Schwerpunkt auf Kubernetes und Cloud in Deutschland.
Ist das ne AI-Stimme?
Die Dinger sind ja mittlerweile so gut,
dass es auch durchaus sein kann,
dass das einer ist, der einfach nur gelangweilt spricht.
Das ist AI, oder?
Plattform-Ingenieure sind die Baumeister der digitalen Infrastruktur.
Ja, das ist AI!
Das ist AI-generated Video!
Lol, Leute!
Der Text ist auch AI-generated!
100 pro!
Sie entwerfen, bauen und warten moderne, flexible und hochverfügbare Multi-Cloud-Kurse.
Das ist Chat-GPT.
Ich will ein Video über Kubernetes-Admin machen.
Ich brauch, ich brauch Text für das Video.
Das ist komplett AI-generated, das Video.
...Kubernetes-Plattformen.
Das Video!
Ich wette mit euch, der Text, die Stimme und das Videomaterial ist komplett AI-generated.
Ihre Hauptaufgaben umfassen die Konzeption und Implementierung, die Sie in der Video-Kurse machen.
... mit Plattform-as-a-Service-Lösungen und mindestens einem der größten Hyperscaler...
Hyperscaler!
... EKS, AKS, GKE ist ein Muss.
Ich sag euch doch, Leute, Hyperscaler, so heißt das halt.
Die sagen alle nicht mal Cloud-Anbieter, Hyperscaler ist es.
... Kenntnisse in der Containerisierung und Kubernetes sind unerlässlich.
Das durchschnittliche Jahresgehalt...
Boah, ist das Video schlecht, Mann!
Das ist 100% komplett AI-generated.
... eines Plattform-Ingenieurs in Deutschland beträgt rund 80.000 Euro.
Aber wie BI allen Berufen kann das...
Aber wie, wie BI allen Berufen?
... in Deutschland beträgt rund 80.000 Euro.
Aber wie BI...
... allen Berufen kann das Gehalt je nach Erfahrung, Standort und Unternehmen variieren.
Oh, ist das schlecht! Ist das schlecht, Mann!
Meine Güte!
Das war wirklich komplett AI-generated Content.
Ey, gleich Abonnieren und Glocke an!
Wie viel Views? K50 oder so.
Boah, war das schlecht!
Was ein Schrott!
Irgendwie rutscht.
Jetzt hat Kabel die ganze Zeit hier runter.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Jeden Tag im OP, was verdient ein...
Oh, das kann ich wieder nicht aussprechen.
Anästhesie?
Anästhesie-technischer Assistent Atta.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das sind IDE-Festplatten.
Lohnt sich das?
Wisst ihr, was meine Vermutung ist?
Meine Vermutung ist, dass sich das nicht lohnt.
Allerdings...
Anders als man denkt.
Und zwar, ich glaube, die Bezahlung ist gar nicht so mies.
Die wird jetzt nicht super krass sein, aber gar nicht so mies.
Aber mir wäre die Verantwortung und der Stress es nicht wert.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Vielleicht das erste Mittel. Das ist ein starkes Schmerzmittel.
Wenn man es nicht schaffen sollte, hat man maximal sechs Minuten,
bis tatsächlich was lebensbedrohlich werden kann.
Ich bin mit meinem Gehalt ganz zufrieden, muss ich sagen.
Hallo, ich bin Recep, 28 Jahre alt.
Ich arbeite an der Charité als anästhesie-technischer Assistent.
Hat das die Dr. House Intro-Musik?
Schon zu lange her, dass ich das geguckt habe.
Wobei ich finde, Dr. House...
Also, ich habe nicht alle Staffeln geguckt.
Das wurde mir irgendwann zu abgedreht.
Aber gerade in den ersten 1-2 Staffeln hatten die ein paar richtig gute Zitate drin.
Zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit...
Sprichst du mit Gott, bist du religiös? Sprich Gott mit dir, bist du verrückt?
Ich finde, das trifft es einfach richtig gut.
Da nehme ich euch gerne mit.
Als Anästhesie-Kollege arbeite ich natürlich in vielen Bereichen.
Sowohl in Neuroschulgie als auch Orthopädie, Allgemeinschulgie und natürlich HNO.
Heute stehen 5 OPs an.
Erstmal gehen wir direkt in den Saal.
Da sollten wir alles kontrollieren.
Wisst ihr, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache loswerden.
Das hat nichts mit ihm zu tun.
Wisst ihr, was eine Sache ist, die mich so gesundheitssystemtechnisch stört?
Das hat auch nicht unbedingt was mit der Qualität zu tun, weil da sind wir im internationalen Vergleich gar nicht übel.
Was mich stört ist, dass das alles so nach Massenabfertigung mittlerweile aussieht und organisiert ist und wirkt.
So nach unpersönlicher Massenabfertigung wirkt für mich das meiste Medizinische mittlerweile.
Das war es in gewisser Weise sicherlich schon immer.
Aber ich glaube, früher konnten sich die Leute mehr Zeit für die eigentlichen Patienten machen.
Also ich weiß das von meiner Mutter, die war Krankenschwester im Krankenhaus auf der Kinderstation.
Und die ist irgendwann weg, weil sie gesagt hat, sie hat eigentlich gar keine Zeit mehr gehabt, sich um die Kinder zu kümmern.
Sondern war nur noch mit anderem Zeug drum herum beschäftigt.
Früher hat sie gesagt, konntest du beispielsweise auch mal, wenn du wusstest, okay, der verträgt den und den Brei nicht,
dann haben sie irgendwas extra an das gekocht.
Aber das eine Kind und sowas, das war halt einfach nicht möglich.
Und das könnt ihr euch überlegen, weil das meine Mutter war.
Und die damals vom Krankenhaus weg ist, das ist ewig her.
Das ist ewig her, also wahrscheinlich 30 Jahre her oder so.
Ich bin jetzt 39, da weiß ich nicht, ja wahrscheinlich ist das 30 Jahre her.
Also das ist wirklich ewig her.
Also das ist super, super unpersönlich und das wirkt alles so nach Massenabfertigung.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, ich habe mittlerweile echt gute Erfahrungen mitgemacht,
wenn man selbst bezahlt bei kleineren Sachen.
Also wenn man zu einem Arzt geht, der normalerweise nur Privatversicherte nimmt.
Und je nachdem, wenn man das mit denen im Vorfeld klärt, nach welchem Satz die abrechnen und sowas.
Die meisten haben es sogar auf ihrer Webseite stehen.
Kann man das, wenn es nichts Großes ist, durchaus selbst bezahlen.
Und man bekommt eine viel, viel bessere Leistung.
Man bekommt eine viel, viel bessere Behandlung.
Kostet ein bisschen was, aber je nachdem was es ist, lohnt sich das.
Wenn es natürlich große Sachen sind, kannst du das nicht selbst bezahlen.
Es sei denn, du bist Privatversichert.
Wo ich immer noch ein bisschen unschlüssig bin, genug Kohle habe ich ja.
Aber immer noch ein bisschen unschlüssig bin, ob ich mir das geben möchte.
Auch weil das, also ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, eines der Sachen, die für mich nach nervig klingen ist.
Dass du nicht einfach zum Arzt gehen kannst, indem du deine Karte in die Hand drücken kannst.
Und dann wird das abgerechnet.
Sondern dass du immer den Kram irgendwie zugeschickt bekommst.
Fotografieren musst, über die App hochladen musst und sowas.
Und dann, ich weiß nicht, ich spreche nicht aus persönlicher Erfahrung, weil ich es noch nicht ausprobiert habe.
Aber irgendwie finde ich, klingt das nervig.
Zumal ich halt wenig.
Dürftest du wechseln?
Jaja, dürfte ich.
Dürfte ich.
Ich habe vor, weiß ich nicht, ist schon eine Weile her.
Du kriegst ja so einen Brief, dass du jetzt über den Mindestbeitrag liegst.
Ist schon lange drüber.
Und wenn ich das mache, dann müsste ich es halt jetzt machen.
Weil ich werde in dem Jahr 40.
Eigentlich ist das nach 40 Jahren, wenn man so den Geiz glaubt im Internet, nicht mehr sinnvoll.
Also von der Kohle her ist das nicht das Ding.
Es ist halt letztendlich, es ist eine Wette wie vieles.
Du spekulierst halt und es kostet halt ordentlich Geld.
Letztendlich kostet aber die gesetzliche Versicherung auch ordentlich Geld.
So ist es gar nicht.
Ja, statistisch gesehen.
Ne.
Ne, ne.
Ich glaube, wie alt werden Männer?
Statistisch 80 oder nur 75 oder so.
Ja, wenn die Männer nur im Durchschnitt nur 75 werden.
Ja.
Und genau das, also man muss sagen, es ist wirklich Zweiklassenmedizin.
Also ich war schon ein paar Mal jetzt selbst bezahlen bei kleineren Sachen.
Ja, beim Hautarzt zum Beispiel war ich jetzt zur Untersuchung schon mal oder auch zum Nachgucken von manchen Sachen.
Es war halt easy.
Beim anderen Hautarzt war das so drei, vier Monate.
Da ist dir schon quasi der Kopf abgefault, wenn du da irgendwas hast.
Oder es ist nicht schlimm und wieder weg.
So nach dem Motto.
Also das ist ein Riesenunterschied.
Und ja, aber da kriegst du keinen schnelleren Termin und so weiter.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe bisher nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Außer einmal, da war ich bei einem HNO-Arzt in Frankfurt.
Und da haben sie Zeug abgerechnet, was sie überhaupt nicht gemacht haben.
Ja.
Also ich habe bisher nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Es geht alles viel schneller.
Man hat mehr Zeit.
Man wird besser behandelt.
Und am Ende geht es einem besser danach.
Also ich muss mal auch wieder ein Beispiel bringen, wo wir gerade schon bei meiner Mutter gewesen sind.
Die hatte vor einer ganzen Weile, hatte die Probleme an der Hüfte.
Da war irgendwas entzündet.
Das kam aber erst nachher raus.
Ja, irgendwas entzündet.
Also sie hat jetzt im Gelenk irgendwas entzündet.
Ja, die wochenlang konnte sie nicht richtig schlafen und so.
Weil im Liegen hat es weh getan und gedrückt und so.
War übelst kacke.
Und ich habe gleich zu ihr gesagt, damals schon.
Ey, lass doch mal.
Also ich habe gegoogelt.
Äh.
Orthopäden hier.
Frankfurt, Hanau und Umgebung.
Lass doch mal da hin.
Der hat richtig gute Bewertungen.
Der schreibt sogar explizit schon auf seiner Webseite, die rechnen bei Selbstbezahlung nur einfach einen Satz ab.
So teuer kann das gar nicht werden, wenn wir da nicht uns operieren, wenn du dich da nicht operieren lässt oder so.
Lass uns das doch mal zumindest angucken bei dem.
Und da wollte sie nicht.
Dann ist sie dann zum Hausarzt.
Der Hausarzt hat gesagt, ach, dann machen wir ein bisschen Wärmebehandlung und sowas.
Was gerade bei Entzündungen das Falsche ist.
Weil Entzündungen werden schlechter, wenn du sie wärmst.
Zumindest wenn die schon sich quasi ausgebreitet haben.
Und da hat sie sich Schmerzmittel geben lassen beim Hausarzt.
Da hat sie Kreislaufprobleme gekriegt.
Danach.
Dann ist sie nochmal zum Hausarzt hin.
Hat sich nochmal Wärmebehandlung machen lassen.
Ist doch auch nicht besser geworden.
Hat sich nochmal Schmerzmittel geben lassen.
Und.
Dann.
Eines Abends hat sie mich angerufen.
Hat gesagt.
Hier Max.
Wir müssen den Krankenwagen rufen.
Ich habe Herzprobleme.
An dem gleichen Tag nachdem sie das Schmerzmittel gekriegt hat.
Was halt ziemlich blöd war.
Weil beim ersten Mal hat sie schon Kreislaufprobleme gehabt.
Dann habe ich den Krankenwagen gerufen.
Und.
Kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Wenn ihr für die Mutter den Krankenwagen ruft.
Da habt ihr schon ein bisschen Schiss dabei.
Kann ja immer.
Man mag ja seine Eltern in der Regel.
Und dann kann er schon mal nach hinten losgehen.
Gerade wenn die Mutter sagt Herzprobleme.
Und da kam der Notarzt.
Hat Blutdruck gemessen.
Herzfrequenz gemessen.
Und die hatte einen Puls von 230.
230.
Als sie im Bett gelegen hat abends.
Und das war.
Wahrscheinlich verursacht durch das Schmerzmittel.
Was sie beim Doktor gegeben hat.
Was sie gekriegt hat.
Der hat sich halt auch null dafür interessiert.
Das war eine Massenabfertigung beim Hausarzt.
Innerhalb von 30 Sekunden.
Ja hier machen wir nochmal schnell next.
Und dann war sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus.
Da ist es nicht besser geworden.
Ja ja 230 ist mega krass.
Das höchste was ich jemals hatte in meinem Leben.
Ist glaube ich irgendwie 205 oder so.
Und das war beim.
Also als ich noch.
Als ich noch wirklich jung war.
Beim vollen Sprint die Brücke hoch.
So 500 Meter.
Ja könnte man vermuten.
Neuester C++ Standard Reveal geguckt.
Also jetzt ist das höchste was ich schaffe.
Glaube ich 192.
Oder 193 hatte ich maximal mal.
Da war ich voll im Arsch.
So und zumindest es wird ja noch besser.
Die war dann im Krankenhaus eine Weile.
Irgendwie knapp knapp.
Ja die mussten dann feststellen.
Das es kein Herzinfarkt ist.
Und sonst was.
Und dann haben sie ja Medikamente gegeben.
Die muss jetzt immer noch welche nehmen.
Das der Blutdruck und die Herzfrequenz.
Und so alles nicht mehr so.
Ja aber das stimmt nicht ganz.
Also bei mir stimmt es nicht.
Weil ich komme auf 192, 193.
Und ich bin jetzt fast 40.
Also dürfte ich eigentlich nur 180 haben.
Also genau stimmt das nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen wie alles individuell.
So zumindest.
Das ganze ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Die war dann im Krankenhaus.
Im Krankenhaus hat man sich nicht wirklich um die Hüfte gekümmert.
Weil die gesagt haben.
Ja sie sind ja hier wegen Herzkreislauf.
Und nicht wegen Hüfte.
Was dann auch schon echt affig ist.
Stell dir mal vor.
Du hast da eine Rentnerin die im Bett liegt.
Und sagt.
Ah alter ich kann mich nicht drehen.
Mir tut alles weh.
Und die Hüfte ich kann nicht schlafen.
Wie die mal so angeguckt hat.
Und da meinte dann.
Ja er sagt mal der Ärztin Bescheid.
Dass die mal guckt danach.
Da kam die Ärztin rein.
Hat sich in der Patientin geirrt.
Hat sich die Hüfte angeguckt.
Von der Nähe bei ihr.
Und da meinte meine Mutter.
Ich glaube sie sind falsch mit Hüfte.
Sie wollen zu mir.
Nein, nein, nein, hier ist schon alles richtig.
Hängen sie sich mal nicht rein.
Boah ich hätte die so.
Das Dumme ist, ich hab's am Ende, das ist halt auch wieder richtig kacke gewesen, ich hab's dann am Ende wieder an denen ausgelassen, die dort eigentlich nur am Empfang sitzen und nix dafür können.
Das ist halt auch kacke, da kriegen sie immer die Falschen ab.
So, und dann ging das Ganze weiter, danach ist sie nochmal, war das das Stadtkrankenhaus?
Soll ich das sagen? Ja, das war das Stadtkrankenhaus.
Und es war nicht das zweite, sondern, also wir haben ja zwei in Hanau, wir haben das St. Vincents Krankenhaus und das Stadtkrankenhaus, aber das war im Stadtkrankenhaus.
Voll für den Arsch.
So, zumindest weiter, danach ist die nochmal wegen der Hüfte auf die Orthopädieabteilung im, ich glaub dann im St. Vincents Krankenhaus gegangen.
So, und dort war der Chef, oder ich weiß nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaub, der Chef von dieser Orthopädieabteilung, der Obermacker, der hat die untersucht und hat ihr während der Untersuchung, das ist kein Witz, während der Untersuchung, also so hat sie mir das erzählt, während der Untersuchung hat er ihr schon erzählt, dass das durchaus sein kann, dass man die Hüfte operieren muss und wie sie da steht zum Thema Hüft-OP, ob sie mit sowas einverstanden wäre, noch während der Untersuchung, der wusste nicht mal, was es ist.
Wollte er nicht.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, ich wieder Schmerzmittel, dann lande ich wieder im Krankenhaus und da meinte er so, ja, okay, was, was haben sie denn bekommen?
Und da hat sie halt erzählt, weil die kennt sich ja mit sowas aus, wie gesagt, die hat ja früher im Krankenhaus gearbeitet, hat sie ihm das erzählt, so welche Schmerzmittel sie bekommen hat und hat er gemeint, ja, das ist altes Zeug, das verschreibt er gar nicht mehr, da wollten sie wieder 5 Cent sparen.
Nee, nee, er macht was anderes, das ist nur örtlich und alles, keine Sorge.
Und ohne Mist, das hat innerhalb von ein paar Tagen, war das nachvollziehbar.
Das hat innerhalb von ein paar Tagen, war das nachvollziehbar.
Ja, zu weg.
Die konnte wieder ohne Probleme laufen, hat keine Schmerzen mehr gehabt beim Liegen.
Die war nach eineinhalb Wochen da.
Der hat das nochmal Ultraschalten, hat gemeint, ja, nice, alles weg.
Und, also, ja, gut, der hat nicht gesagt, ja, nice, alles weg, aber sinngemäß.
Sagt er, ja, nice, alles weg, bisschen, bisschen was an der Seite noch.
So soll jetzt, ist nicht total übertreiben, die nächsten paar Wochen.
Und wenn es, wenn es wirklich schlechter wird, soll es vorbeikommen, aber er glaubt, das ist jetzt wieder alles gut.
Und es ist.
Und, alles gut bis jetzt gewesen.
So, und ich weiß, was das gekostet hat, weil es war viel billiger, als ich gedacht habe.
Ich meine, ich habe ja, wie gesagt, ich habe das ja schon ein paar Mal für mich selbst gemacht.
Und dementsprechend wusste ich im Vorfeld, was man fragen muss.
Also man geht nie zu so einem Arzt hin und lässt sich einfach behandeln, ja.
Man fragt, man sagt, man bezahlt das selbst und man fragt die, mit welchem Satz die in der Regel abrechnen.
Weil, weil.
Es ist so, es gibt so eine Gebührenordnung für Ärzte, wo sich auch, ja, privat, äh, private Ärzte dann dran halten müssen.
Also es ist ja hauptsächlich auch für, für private Ärzte gedacht.
Die, die mit, mit Krankenkasse und so, die können das ja eh nur nach den Deals mit der Krankenkasse abrechnen.
Es gibt so eine, es gibt so eine Gebührenordnung für Ärzte, da steht das halt drinnen, was die Sachen kosten.
So, und diese, das, was dort drinnen steht, kann multipliziert werden zwischen mal 1 bis mal 2,3.
Alles, was über 2,3 ist, oder was, was 2,8, nee, ich glaub 2,3.
Alles, was über 2,3 ist, müssen die explizit begründen, warum es mehr abgerechnet wird.
Also zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, ähm, du lässt dir was am Ohr machen und dein Ohr ist, in deinem Ohr ist zickzack und da kommt es richtig rein oder so.
Ja, dann sagt er, okay, wir rechnen mal 3,5 ab, weil es doppelt so lang gedauert hat.
Weil, weil er irgendwie Winkel im Ohr hat.
Winkel im Ohr hat, die normale Menschen nicht haben.
Das müssen die dann begründen.
G-Ö-Äh, G-Ö-Äh, klingt richtig, ja.
Und zumindest, deswegen immer fragen, so mit welchem Satz die normalerweise abrechnen.
Die meisten machen, wenn du nichts fragst, automatisch mal 2,3.
Aber, nachdem das ja eine ganz so, so private, wie soll man sagen, das ist keine, was ist das, ein Werksvertrag?
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie man das rechtlich nennt.
Zumindest, wenn du das im Vorfeld mit denen vereinbarst und wenn du sagst, ja, sagen wir mal, was kosten das ungefähr?
Und wie wird das abgerechnet?
Dann sagen die dir auch was drauf.
Und wenn die sagen, ja, wenn wir so normale, das und das von normalen Sachen ausgehen, 200 Euro.
Und da können die nicht einfach 500 Euro abrechnen.
Also, das ist, das ist, wie wenn du bei irgendeinem Handwerker quasi im Vorfeld sagst, hier, machen sie mir mal einen Kostenvoranschlag.
Und der sagt 300 Euro und rechnet dann 1.500 ab.
Dann funktioniert, funktioniert das nicht.
So, und zumindest, ich hatte die auch gefragt, wie die normalerweise abrechnen.
Und das stand auch schon auf der Homepage.
Die haben gesagt, also, ja, wenn es, ja.
Normaler Aufwand ist, dann rechnen die mal 1,0 ab.
Was, was wirklich günstig ist.
Weil, wie gesagt, normalerweise rechnen die alle mal 2,3 ab.
So, und wie gesagt, Ende gut, alles gut.
Bei ihr kein Problem mehr.
Und am Ende hat es gekostet, jetzt haltet euch fest, wir waren, muss man dazu sagen, wir waren einmal knapp eine halbe Stunde drin.
Ich war natürlich dabei, ich wollte gucken, was der macht für, für mein Geld, ja.
Ähm, und ein zweites Mal nochmal eine Viertelstunde.
Das waren insgesamt 45 Minuten beim Arzt.
Drinne, wo sie behandelt wurde.
Und am Ende hat das gekostet.
Ich bin mir nicht auf den Centbetrag, äh, mehr sicher, aber ich glaube, 104 Euro.
104,80 Euro oder sowas.
104 Euro!
Das ist nix!
Ich persönlich habe irgendwas mit 300, 400 Euro gerechnet, das ist nix!
100, 104.
Ey, 150 hätte ich auch nichts gesagt, es war super billig.
Ja.
Und das mit, das, was der, was der dort gemacht hat, hätte der Typ im Krankenhaus garantiert auch machen können.
Kannst du, klar, kannst du.
Ähm, das hätte der Typ im Krankenhaus auch machen können, weil der hat das festgestellt, hat aber nichts gemacht.
Also voll für den Arsch.
Tja.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Steuerabsetzen geht, vom Krankenhausbetrag geht nicht.
Tja.
Und was mich auch wieder darin bestärkt hat,
dass es durchaus Sinn macht, zum privaten Arzt zu gehen.
Ja, ob das teurer ist, kann man sich drüber streiten.
Weil, je nachdem wie viel Geld man da hat, kann man sich darüber streiten.
Je nachdem, was du für einen Vertrag machst, musst du ja im Zweifelsfall auch, wenn du älter wirst, mehr bezahlen.
Das ist eine Planungssache.
Also im Prinzip, wie vieles, so eine Wette auf die Zukunft,
ob du krank wirst, ob du nicht krank wirst, und es ist auch ein bisschen so ein Sicherheitsgefühl,
manche brauchen mehr, manche brauchen weniger,
ist wie mit allen Versicherungen.
Muss jeder selbst wissen.
Zahlst du noch in die Rente ein?
Ja, tatsächlich mache ich.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, ob ich mir das aussuchen dürfte.
Krankenkasse darf ich mir aussuchen.
Rente ist mir nicht bewusst, dass ich mir das aussuchen darf.
Weil es wichtig ist, bei sowas konstant zu sein und man das dann auch nicht vergisst.
Ich bezahle immer ab und zu und dann halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 6.000, 7.000 Euro, wenn es mir danach ist.
Also das Letzte, was ich überwiesen habe, waren glaube ich, Moment, lass mich mal gucken, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Das waren glaube ich irgendwie 4.000 Euro Ende des Jahres, Ende letzten Jahres.
Wo sieht man das eigentlich gescheit?
Sieht man das bei Scalable? Man muss das doch bei Scalable irgendwo sehen, Profil.
Das sieht man doch irgendwo, wo man was gekauft hat, oder?
Ja, Transactions.
Ne, minus 5.000 Euro sogar, 5.000 Euro.
Ende letzten Jahres, 5.034,27 Euro.
Davor war im September und dann war im Juli und davor war im Juni.
Also ich mache das immer unregelmäßig, im Endeffekt kommt es wahrscheinlich aufs Gleiche raus.
Aber es wäre durchaus sinnvoll, ich gebe euch recht, Schätge, es wäre durchaus sinnvoll, das kontinuierlich zu machen.
Dass man sagt, so keine Ahnung, jeden Monat 500 Euro oder sowas.
Einfach, dann ist das weg, da muss man sich keine großen Gedanken machen.
Und man kann es nicht vergessen.
Hast du die Seite jetzt erst entdeckt, Chandler?
Beispiel für den Raid.
Von 60k auf 82k würde der Lohn steigen.
Also 22.000 Euro mehr.
Ja, das ist in der Tat nicht wenig, aber das ist schon ordentlich.
Was sind das, 30% mehr oder so?
10% sind 6, 12, mehr.
So 30% mehr oder so, das ist schon ordentlich.
Ob es mir wert wäre, kommt drauf an, wie viel der Unterschied ist.
Also ich persönlich, schwer zu sagen, 60 auf 2, das ist halt schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied.
Ja.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht auf Homeoffice verzichten, weil mehr machen können, worauf man Bock hat,
weil man mehr Zeit am Tag hat, ist halt, echt, das ist was echt Persönliches.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Wenn jetzt natürlich noch andere Sachen auf den Keks gehen bei dem alten Job,
dass es nicht nur rein das Geld ist, dann schon.
Also ich, ich würde es mal, ich kann es ja nicht für dich entscheiden, wie das,
wie das gewichtet ist für dich, ja.
Also wenn die alten Sachen, wenn im alten Job Sachen auf den Keks gehen
und die neuen so viel bessere Bedingungen haben, plus mehr Geld, dann würde ich es auch machen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, richtig.
Der Lohn würde von 60 auf 200 und Homeoffice von drei, von fünf auf drei Tagen runter.
Ähm, das ist okay.
Ich, ganz ehrlich, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, du hast ja auch gerade geschrieben,
beim alten Arbeitgeber gehen dir auch ein paar Sachen auf den Keks.
Ich, ich, ich finde,
das ist okay.
Eins bis zwei Tage Office die Woche kann man sich gerade so noch geben
und dafür dann 30 Prozent mehr Geld und ein besseres Arbeitsumfeld.
Das ist, denke ich, nicht schlecht, ja.
Vielleicht bekommst du aber auch bei deinem, bei deinem jetzigen Laden auch mehr,
wenn du das denen sagst.
Also nur, nur wenn du das andere schon sicher, sicher auf dem Tisch liegen hast, ne.
Ja, das ist ein gutes E-Mode.
Mich wundert, dass der EQ-Counter,
bei so niedrig anfängt, guck mal, der fängt nur bei 120 an.
Da muss der, da muss der Chat aber schon im Durchschnitt drüber sein hier.
120, das ist ja nix, bei so vielen Prime-Subs.
So, was haben wir, was kommen wir zu?
Ach, wir waren, wir waren, Alter, ich hab mich so krass sidetracken lassen jetzt, gell.
Wir wollten eigentlich das Video angucken, ob es sich lohnt als Anästhesie-technischer
IDE-Festplattenassistent.
Lull.
Okay, dann gucken wir das Video doch jetzt mal.
Funktionsbereit ist...
Kontrolle der OP-Geräte.
... so ein Narkose-Gerät.
Sieht gut aus.
Ich muss, ich muss tatsächlich noch was dazu sagen.
Weil es, weil es mich selbst verwundert hat.
Ihr habt doch beim Zahnarzt bestimmt schon mal eine Betäubung bekommen, ja?
Ich hab letztens drüber was gelesen und das hat einfach zu gut gepasst.
Und zwar habt ihr auch manchmal das Gefühl, dass,
dass, wenn ihr eine Betäubung beim Zahnarzt bekommt,
dass sich das kreislaufmäßig so ein bisschen komisch anfühlt.
So ganz kurz, nicht lang, aber es fühlt sich ein bisschen komisch an.
Ich hab das, ich hab das immer drauf geschoben, weil man beim Zahnarzt ja aufgeregt ist, ja,
und Spritze und Aufregen und so.
Genau.
Aber da ist Adrenalin drin.
Das ist, also die, das Betäubungsmittel ist eine Mischung aus, ähm, Schmerzmittel,
Adrenalin und...
und, ähm, Entspannung, nee, äh, warte mal, äh, äh,
ach, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Schmerzmittel,
irgendwie Betäubungsmittel und, und Adrenalin zumindest.
Und deswegen kommt einem das kreislaufmäßig auch so komisch vor.
Und viele Narkosemittel sind eine Mischung quasi so aus unterschiedlichen Sachen.
Also da wird nicht immer nur eins volle Pulle reingepumpt.
Ja, da haben sie dir wahrscheinlich massig reingehauen, hä?
Aber bei Kreislauf, bei Kreislauf, ähm,
äh, äh, äh, bei, äh, bei Weisheitszähnen hast du noch das andere Problem,
dass die dich ja da, je nachdem, ob die oben oder unten sind,
die stellen dich ja da halb auf den Kopf, dass sie richtig rankommen.
Oh, da ist...
So, jetzt aber.
Ich, nur, ist mir nur so nebenbei eingefallen.
Herausforderungen sind halt Zeitdruck manchmal und natürlich die Kälte,
was man hier hat, muss man natürlich die ganze Zeit mit 100% dabei bleiben.
Ah ja, ne?
Jetzt können wir endlich mal, endlich mal Verwendung für das Emo.
jetzt. Super, dass sie das macht. Oh ja, wir kennen uns auch. Ja, wir kennen uns. Hallo noch mal. Ich würde direkt ein paar Fragen stellen. Was machen Sie? Wann haben Sie?
Der macht das gut. Der macht das gut. Ich glaube, der gibt den Leuten das Gefühl, dass sie da gut aufgehoben sind.
Zum letzten Mal was gegessen? Oh, gestern Abend das Abendbrot und das war gegen 18 Uhr vermutlich mal so ungefähr.
Okay, und als nächstes auf die Stirn würde ich eine EEG-Klebschen kleben. Zeigt uns dann während der Narkose, wie tief Sie schlafen.
Ich muss hier und da drücken, damit das Klebschen schön hält. Ich gebe Ihnen schon mal den Sauerstoff.
Neurolink am Start. Und Sie atmen schon mal tief durch, ja?
Mach dir keine Sorgen, bei den meisten Leuten ist das easy.
Gerade wenn du schon ein bisschen älter bist und die halt schon ein bisschen, gehe ich mal von aus,
weil du bist ja schon ein bisschen älter, dann ist das easy.
Du bist hier auf Twitch bei mir am Start. Die meisten Leute sind ein bisschen älter. Ist das kein Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist. Ich habe echt keinen Plan, wie das ist.
Ich habe in meinem Leben nur eine Vollnarkose gehabt und das war, als ich einen Leistenbruch hatte,
wo ich noch ganz klein war. Da hatte ich einen Leistenbruch und musste operiert werden im Krankenhaus.
Da habe ich eine Vollnarkose gekriegt. Und die Vollnarkose bei mir, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
die war nicht mit so einem...
Also, da habe ich nicht so ein Ding drauf gekriegt, sondern die haben mir was gespritzt.
Oder pennt die schon?
Die haben mir was gespritzt. Da war ich instant weg.
Und danach haben die mir die Maske wahrscheinlich aufgezogen. Das habe ich aber gar nicht mehr mitbekommen.
Ich denke, die Maske ist wahrscheinlich für... Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich würde vermuten, diese Atemmaske ist für zwei Dinge.
Einmal zum Kontrollieren der Atmung.
So Sauerstoffgehalt und sowas.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob dort auch irgendwelche Narkosemittel drüber gedingst werden. Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist ja hauptsächlich auch zum Kontrollieren, sodass du gescheit atmest und Sauerstoffgehalt und sowas.
Dass du nicht am Abkratzen bist halt.
Und Sauerstoff... Aber ey, was sie mir... Das war richtig krass, ey.
Das habe ich so... Das habe ich...
Das habe ich so noch vielleicht... Das habe ich so noch nie erlebt, ne?
Das weiß ich noch. Ich habe da im OP gelegen. Da war ich wirklich... Da war ich klein.
Keine Ahnung, wie alt ich damals war, als ich den Leistenbruch hatte.
Da hat meine Mutter noch im Krankenhaus gearbeitet und quasi irgendeine befreundete Ärztin von ihr hat das gemacht.
Und dementsprechend haben die sich auch alle Mühe gegeben.
Du gibst dir halt viel mehr Mühe, wenn du persönlich die Leute kennst, ne?
Und da muss ich... Also wie gesagt, nachdem meine Mutter noch im Krankenhaus... Da war ich vielleicht fünf oder so.
Da war ich wirklich klein. Oder vier, vier, fünf. Da war ich sehr jung.
Zumindest...
Ich habe... Das habe ich... Das habe ich nicht für Möglichkeiten.
Ich habe da drauf gelegen, ja?
Da wird... Da hast du ja die... So wie bei ihr. So wie bei ihr, ne?
Legt da hier der Arm auf so einem Ding, weil da kriegst du ja eine Narkose.
So. Und ich hatte noch vom Blutabnehmen... Hatte ich da noch so einen Zugang hier bei mir schon.
Also die mussten mir das gar nicht spritzen, so.
Die sind da hingegangen, haben da die Spritze dran gemacht und haben mir das in den Arm gespritzt.
Und ich habe noch zum Beispiel... Ich weiß das noch, ja?
Ich habe da keinen Gedächtnisverlust oder so. Ich weiß das noch bis zu dem Moment, wo ich quasi umgekippt bin, so.
Die haben mir das gespritzt und meine Mutter hat noch was... Hat noch was...
Hat noch neben mir gestanden. Ich meinte noch so zu ihr, das weiß ich heute noch.
Ich meinte noch zu ihr so...
Ja, ach so schnell wird das ja nicht wirken.
Und dann weiß ich nichts mehr.
Das war instant. Ich weiß noch... Das Letzte, was ich sagen wollte...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das überhaupt komplett...
...sagen konnte.
Ach, so schnell wirkt das nicht. Bäm.
Nichts mehr. Nichts mehr.
Instant. Instant. Weg.
So.
Und das Nächste, woran ich mich dann wieder erinnern kann, ist...
Ähm, gut, ich meine, Leistenbruch kriegst du ja ein bisschen rumgeschnibbelt an der Hüfte und so.
Weil ich was sagen wollte.
Naja, zumindest wird da ein bisschen rumgeschnibbelt an der Hüfte und wieder zusammengenäht und alles.
Also hast du schon so ein bisschen Verletzungen an der Hüfte.
Zumindest, wenn du dann wieder langsam zu dir kommst.
Du träumst den übelsten Schwachsinn.
Wisst ihr, was ich geträumt habe beim Aufwachen?
Komplett wir. Komplett wir.
Ähm, dadurch, dass man halt da Schmerzen hat, aber es halt nicht checkt, dass es Schmerzen sind.
Ich habe geträumt, ich renne vor einem Feuerball weg, der mich aber immer wieder so an der Hüfte trifft.
Der sah erstaunlich...
Der sah erstaunlicherweise ein bisschen aus, wie so ein Super Mario Feuerball.
Aber es kann kein Super Mario Feuerball gewesen sein, weil...
Ah, wobei...
Ne, kann nicht.
Es kann kein Super Mario Feuerball gewesen sein, weil Super Nintendo habe ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 1992, 93 oder so.
Wann hatte man denn?
Release Date?
Hm, 1990.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das passt.
Ich glaube, das war, bevor ich einen Super Nintendo hatte und ich hatte ihn auch nicht direkt zu Release.
Ich habe geträumt, ich werde von einem Feuerball verfolgt, der mich ab und zu trifft und ich kann gerade noch so wegrennen.
Ja, das war...
Hä? Warum Riesenrad?
Also, das hat mich einfach umgehauen. Das weiß ich nur.
So, weiter.
Ich muss hier und da drücken, damit das Gläbchen schön hält.
Ich gebe Ihnen schon mal den Sauerstoff.
Und Sie atmen schon mal.
Einmal tief durch, ja?
Ja, okay, das ist nur Sauerstoff.
Sie bekommen gleich das erste Mittel. Das ist ein starkes Schmerzmittel.
Kann ein bisschen düselig machen und müde. Genießen Sie das.
Genießen? Naja, genossen habe ich es nicht. Das war einfach nur Bäm, weg.
Jetzt bekommen Sie auch ein Schlafmittel.
Der Patient schläft innerhalb einer bis zwei Minuten schon ein.
Ich nicht. Bei mir hat es fünf Sekunden gedauert.
Kommt eine Relaxanz.
Ich war einfach weg.
Wenn man eine Relaxanz dem Patienten gibt, kann ein Patient dann nicht mehr atmen, kann...
Ähm, deswegen dürfen die auch nichts essen, oder?
Weil, weil wenn du dich entspannst und noch, ich sag mal, Sachen ready to kacken hast, dann...
Ich muss das nicht ausführen, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
...keine von seinen Muskeln bewegen.
Wenn man es nicht schaffen sollte, hat man maximal sechs...
...minuten bis tatsächlich was...
Das ist so ein Beatmungsschlauch-Ding für die Lunge, oder?
...bewegen.
Wenn man es nicht schaffen sollte, hat man maximal sechs...
Ja, das ist gut, dass du da erstmal Narkose bekommst, weil freiwillig machst du da nicht mit, dir so ein Ding in den Hals stecken zu lassen.
...minuten bis tatsächlich was lebensbedrohlich werden kann.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben vorher alle ordentlich den hier gemacht.
Was als Schlimmes im OP passiert ist, wird auch vergessen, glaube ich.
Sonst, wenn man diese Zwischenfälle mit nach Hause mitnimmt, ist man...
Ich glaube, da kannst du das nicht lange machen, wenn du das, wenn du, wenn du, dann, dann traust du dich nicht mehr.
Wenn, stell dir mal vor, es wird früher oder später irgendwas passieren.
Das lässt sich gar nicht vermeiden.
Ich meine, Leute sind im Krankenhaus, weil sie krank sind.
Ja, und außerdem sind Narkose und Operation nie ungefährlich.
Und dann, dann, dann hast du ja selbst übelst Panik, dann traust du dich nicht mehr irgendwas zu machen.
Dann bist du komplett handlungsunfähig.
Ich glaube, du kannst das gar nicht so dir zu Herzen nehmen.
Sonst machst du das nicht länger als zwei Wochen.
Dann ist man am Ende wahrscheinlich selber krank.
Aber ich kann sagen, dass man seine erste Reanimation und letzten Notfall im Kopf noch hat.
Die beide bleiben.
Ja, bin ich jetzt fertig.
Und jetzt, ich kümmere mich um die Bestellung von den nächsten Patienten von der Station.
Tatsächlich sollten wir jeden Tag Patienten überlappend einleiten.
Das heißt...
Während die erste OP läuft, sollte ich schon mit den nächsten Patienten anfangen.
Ist halt irgendwie Fließbandarbeit.
Ist nicht so, dass es unbedingt qualitativ schlecht sein muss.
Ich finde, das ist aber so eines der Sachen, weshalb ich persönlich eben kein gutes Gefühl dabei habe.
Es geht letztendlich auch gar nicht anders.
Das ist mir auch klar.
Das muss schon...
Es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn du die Leute dort hast und die eilen.
Ja, die Leute dort sind zu 80 Prozent.
Hüftprothese.
Ja, wir hatten es ja gerade von der Hüfte.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es da Statistiken drüber gibt.
Aber meine persönliche Meinung ist, und ich bilde mir auch ein, das schon gelesen zu haben öfters,
dass gerade was Hüft-OPs und Knie-OPs, wenn da im Nachhinein untersucht wird, wie notwendig das war,
dass dort diese zwei Bereiche, Hüft-OPs und Knie-OPs, die Bereiche sind, wo anteilmäßig am meisten gemacht wird,
weil es Kohle bringt und nicht weil es unbedingt notwendig gewesen wäre.
Sie hat ja viel Schlafmittel plus Schmerzmittel bekommen.
Wird ein bisschen dauern, bis sie wach ist.
Atmen Sie mal tief ein und aus.
Sollen wir den Schlauch ausziehen?
Und den Mund auf.
Ja. Und aufmachen den Mund.
Weit auf.
Super.
Sehr schön. Hm?
Da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Hi, der Gypsy ist ein Neuen. Hättet ihr einen Platz noch?
Sieben. Danke dir.
Platz 7?
Ja, Platz 7 hast du heute.
Hat ein bisschen länger gebraucht, weil er auch großen Bedarf an Schmerzmitteln während der OP hat.
Langsam aufwachen ist völlig normal.
Ich bin gespannt, ob er die Arbeitsstunden auch einhält.
Weil was auf dem Zettel steht und was da gemacht wird,
sind es glaube ich oftmals zwei.
Zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, die werden mit ein, zwei Patienten weniger und weniger Stress und weniger dauerhaft machen
und auf dauerhaft immer alles achten müssen. Genauso routiniert.
Mindestens ein Wochenende im Monat muss ich arbeiten.
Für Wochenende, Feiertage und auch Nachtdienste gibt es natürlich Zuschläge.
Mehr nicht?
Da bekomme ich ja mehr für ein Wochenende einfach nur random rumsitzen in der Rufbereitschaft.
Gibt es OPs?
Ohne Anruf.
Zuschlag, dass wir in einer geschlossenen Station im OP-Bereich arbeiten, bekommen wir dafür auch einen Zuschlag,
weil wir in Kälte sind und weil es stressiger ist, weil wir mit uns sind.
Gab es das Monat, gab es das Gehalt schon eigentlich?
Ne, es gab nur die Zulage bisher, ja?
Zeitdruck umgehen.
Hallo ihr Lieben.
Guten Appetit.
Dankeschön.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Mit 100 Euro im Monat Essen komme ich nicht hin.
Zumindest nicht in Frankfurt.
Glücklicherweise muss ich nicht mehr so oft nach Frankfurt.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Ich glaube, dass der Verdienst gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Aber das ganze Drumherum, ich könnte es mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Naja, man muss sagen, so krass ist es auch nicht.
Das sieht immer, Brutto sieht immer so viel aus.
Aber ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, das sind dann im Prinzip auch nur mal 12, je nachdem wie viel die kriegen.
Plus seine Zulagen.
Sagen wir mal so, der ist bei 60k oder so.
Vielleicht am Ende des Jahres.
Weiß nicht, ob es 12 oder 13 Gehälter sind.
Das muss man gucken.
Und der bezahlt dann da auch massig Steuern drauf.
Also so krass große Steuern.
Es ist nicht schlecht im Vergleich zu vielen.
Wenn du mal in den Durchschnitt gehst, das ist nicht schlecht.
Also mega Sprünge kannst du damit auch nicht machen.
Und es ist Vollzeit.
Erstmal hinsetzen kurz.
Knieprothese.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Das ist besonders, dass der Patient die ganze Zeit wach ist und ansprechbar.
Aber möchte trotzdem ein bisschen sediert werden.
Das heißt, wird trotzdem ansprechbar bleiben.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich würde mich auch betäuben lassen, wenn einer einmal im Knie rumschnippelt.
Aber ein bisschen müde und schläfrig.
Dafür haben wir auch ein paar Medikamente.
Uh, kriegt der so einen Rücken?
Nadel in den Rücken und so jetzt?
Oh, das ist Sack, Alter.
Immer, wenn ich das schon sehe, kriege ich Anfälle.
Sehr gut.
Nicht wegzucken, ist alles gut.
Es kann mal so ein elektrisches Ziehen geben.
Jetzt bleibe ich die ganze Zeit hier bei Ihnen.
Während der Kollege von hinten drückt, würde ich Sie unterstützen.
Ja, okay.
Oh.
Die S***.
Bonkes.
Sich verknöchern.
Komplett schon verbogen.
Ein bisschen komplizierter, naja.
Okay.
Nein, der Jeff hier kann uns ein bisschen helfen, Alter.
Spinnaren, danke.
Jetzt kommt die Expertin.
Die ist da nicht so zimperlich.
Oh, ey.
Thema Nadeln.
Keine Sorge, wird nicht abarten.
Wird jetzt nicht so schlimm wie das hier.
Ich mach mal kurz weg.
Ich musste mal einen MRT machen, wo du dann in so ein Magnetdings reingeschoben wirst.
Und da kriegst du so Kontrastmittel gespritzt.
Du kriegst quasi so an der einen Seite, du kriegst da so eine, das tut nicht weh.
Das ist wirklich eine ganz, ganz mini, dünne, kleine Nadel, die du da reinkriegst.
Das merkst du kaum.
Und da wird dann so Kontrastmittel durchgeleitet.
Durchgeleitet, dass du das besser siehst, ja.
Das Blöde war nur bei mir, als die mich da rein...
Also, dann wird da das Kontrastmittel angeschlossen.
Als die mich da reingefahren haben, hat sich der Schlauch quasi von dem Kontrastmittel noch...
Der war ein bisschen gewunden und der hat sich quasi entwunden, dadurch, dass ich da reingefahren wurde, ja.
Also, das war quasi...
Müsst ihr euch das so vorstellen.
Also, so stell ich mir das vor.
Ich hab's ja nicht gesehen, nur gemerkt.
Ich geh mal davon aus, der Schlauch für das Kontrastmittel lag halt noch ein bisschen so, ja.
Und die haben mich dann da reingefahren und dann hat sich halt diese Schlaufe langsam entschlauft und so.
Und dadurch hatte das aber ein bisschen mehr Widerstand.
Und wenn ihr einen Schlauch an der Nadel hängen habt und ihr werdet bewegt und die Nadel dreht sich dann bei euch im Arm, das tut weh.
Ich hab dann rumgezappelt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich...
Ich glaube, ich hab nichts Böses gesehen.
Ich glaube, ich hab nichts Böses gesagt.
Ich hab einfach nur ein bisschen rumgezappelt und hab mit der anderen Hand ein bisschen gegen die Mauer gehauen.
Also, gegen das Teil beim Reinfahren gehauen.
Und dann wird's ja beobachtet und die sehen das.
Und dann haben die angehalten, sind wieder reingekommen und gut.
Okay, gucken wir mal. Fertig.
Jetzt sind wir an der richtigen Stelle.
Also, am schlimmsten Blutabnehmen bei mir war einmal, als der Azubi das gemacht hat bei mir.
Beim Arzt.
Und ich war auch so blöd noch, ne.
Ging halt drum.
So nach dem Motto...
Ja, der...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das genau gewesen ist.
Ich wurde irgendwie gefragt, ob der Azubi das machen darf, ja.
Und das war halt so eine junge, blonde, hübsche Auszubildende.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ja, ja, klar.
Da will man halt so ein bisschen...
Möchte man da so ein bisschen auf cool machen, ne.
Und hab gesagt, ja, kein Problem.
Das kann die an mir ausprobieren.
Und die hat das an mir ausprobiert, Blut abnehmen.
Und...
Die hat es noch nicht so richtig drauf, äh...
Blut abnehmen war gar kein Problem.
Halla, Chainlord.
Ähm...
Blut abnehmen war gar kein Problem.
Die hat...
Da denkst du, oh, Blut abgenommen, so wunderbar, alles gut, alles gut.
Aber dann hat sie den Fehler gemacht.
Du musst ja beim Blut abnehmen...
Du musst ja draufdrücken auf die Stelle, wo reingestochen wurde beim Nadel rausziehen.
Und die hat nicht richtig draufgedrückt.
Und hat dann irgendwie ein bisschen so...
Bisschen noch, ich weiß nicht, die Ader aufgeschnitten oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Und das Witzige daran war, paar Tage später hatte ich immer noch so einen Pfluderguss am Arm.
Und ich bin nach Frankfurt gegangen.
Und ihr glaubt das nicht.
Die ganzen Obdachlosen und Drogenabhängigen in Frankfurt, die waren noch nie so nett zu mir.
Ich bin da vorbeigelaufen an unserem alten Gebäude.
Da hingen sie immer.
Da sind immer so alte...
Ja, einer von uns haben die sich gedacht, garantiert.
Da bin ich vorbeigelaufen.
Die sitzen immer auf so alten, zugemauerten Eingängen, wo noch Treppen davor sind.
Da bin ich da vorbeigelaufen.
Und du hast halt so voll...
Ich hatte ein T-Shirt an, das war warm.
So voll den Pfluderguss am Arm gesehen.
Und der Typ lacht mich so an.
Ja, hallo, hallo.
Und ich denk mir so, Alter, der Typ redet nie mit mir.
Die reden nie mit mir.
Was ist denn da los?
Und ich so, hallo.
Und lauf so vorbei.
Hä, was geht denn ab?
Und irgendwann ist es mir dann gedämmert.
Der Typ hat meinen Arm gesehen und hat sich gedacht, okay, bei so einem Arm...
Der hat sich bestimmt richtig was reingehauen vor noch kurzer Zeit.
Der gibt mir was ab, wenn ich nett zu dem bin.
Der hat hundertprokal gehofft, ich hab noch was.
Und wenn er nett zu mir ist, gibt's was.
Ist nie wieder vorgekommen danach.
Also nachdem der Pfluderguss weg war.
Das sah wirklich eklig aus.
Das war so quasi vom Ellenbogen ab.
Also Innenarm vom Ellenbogen ab.
So bis den halben Arm runter.
War das komplett lila, blau, gelb.
Der Arm.
Jetzt kommt das örtliche Betäubungsmittel.
Okay, okay, die Expertin hat's geschafft.
Das geht jetzt los, ne?
Dauert insgesamt jetzt um zehn Minuten, bis das Kompletthaus ist.
Ein kleines bisschen ist die Wirbelsäule verdreht unten.
Das hat uns grad ein bisschen Probleme gemacht, den frischen Raum richtig zu treffen.
Aber ist alles gut.
Jetzt hat alles gut geklappt.
Ist leider heute wahrscheinlich ein bisschen später abgelöst.
Weil...
Weil der Spätdienst richtig dünn besetzt ist.
Wegen Krankmeldungen.
Das dachte ich mir, dass der nicht bei 39 Stunden bleibt.
Sollten wir eigentlich vor 20 Minuten von hier raus.
So, möchtest du übernehmen?
Ja.
Okay.
Der *** bekommt einen wahrscheinlich septischen Knietapwechsel.
Sollte ungefähr zwei Stunden dauern.
In Ordnung?
Ja, in Ordnung. Alles gut.
Danke dir.
Danke.
Mein Gehalt schwankt jeden Monat tatsächlich.
Ich habe ein Grundgehalt von 3.448 Euro.
TVÖD K-Gruppe P08 Stufe 4.
Die Bezeichnung von den Dingern ist immer richtig...
Das schreit schon so bürokratisches Zeug hier.
Aber die heißen ja alle so.
Und dazu kommen ein paar Zuschlägen.
Ich habe im Dezember 4.005 Euro brutto verdient.
Und dann davon 2.700 Euro.
Das sind 703 Euro netto rausgekommen.
Da kommst du schon mit aus?
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass du davon jetzt irgendwie reich wirst?
Habe ich heute halbe Stunde, Überstunden gemacht.
Ist völlig normal.
Weil im Spätdienst haben wir nur in der Regel acht Mitarbeiter.
Wenn davon zwei krank sind und wir weiterhin 15...
Also ich würde das für die Kohle nicht machen, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Ich würde es aber wahrscheinlich für keine Kohle der Welt machen, sowas.
Aber ich habe bei dem den Eindruck, der macht das, wie soll man das sagen, der macht das professionell.
Aber auf eine Art und Weise, dass die Leute einen guten Eindruck haben, dass sie dort gut aufgehoben sind.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so, oh Herr Müller, schön, dass Sie wieder da sind.
Da kommst du ja auch bescheuert vor, ja.
Aber du hast den Eindruck, okay, der vermittelt erstens, dass er weiß, was er macht.
Das ist ja ein super Beruhigungsgespräch.
Das ist ein super Beruhigungsfaktor.
Stell dir mal vor, du weißt, du bist den Leuten da alle ausgeliefert.
Und das erste, was du siehst, ist irgendeiner da so wirkt, als wüsste er nicht, was er macht.
Das ist schon mal doof, ja.
Der wirkt, was er macht.
Und er gibt den Leuten auch irgendwie so das Gefühl, dass das alles gut funktioniert.
Also hat auf mich so zumindest gewirkt, als fühlen sich die Leute da gut aufgehoben.
Der sieht ganz anders aus ohne Kopftuch.
Ich glaube mittlerweile, dass wir uns eine Wohnung kaufen und dafür, ja.
Der sieht viel jünger aus, so ohne Kopftuch irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Wir gehen ein bisschen zur Seite jeden Monat.
Aber halt bis man darauf kommt, dass man 20 Prozent von Kreditbetrag halt zusammen kriegt, dauert halt noch ein Jahr.
Er auf Kredite sagt halt immer, jawoll, oh.
Wir rollen gleich mal.
Was für eine Feine.
Ich muss das E-Mode ab und zu mal benutzen, ja.
Wir rollen gleich mal den Baller mal raus.
Das Instrument, das ich mittlerweile seit ein paar Monaten lerne.
Das ist eigentlich kein Lied, nur wie gesagt eine Übung.
Lohnt sich das?
Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Soll ich mehr sagen?
Glaube ja.
Ich bin mit meinem Gerät ganz zufrieden, muss ich sagen.
Könnte es auf jeden Fall.
Katzenversicherung, ob ich auch eine für meine Katze habe, nee.
Aber ich habe keine Katze aktuell mehr.
Aber das würde wahrscheinlich.
Chico, weil leider nicht mehr unter uns.
Seit Dezember letzten Jahres.
Meinen Alltag nicht so viel ändern.
Ich dachte, das habt ihr mitbekommen.
Ich habe es auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich meine, ich will das nicht jedem Stream erzählen.
Sadge.
Doch, klar.
Twitter.
Ja, X.
X.
Ja, richtig sad.
Wisst ihr, was richtig sad ist daran?
Dass Chico bei mir im Kopf immer noch so die neue Katze war, die ich habe.
Dabei hatte ich die ja mit Abstand am längsten.
Und auch irgendwie schon fünf Jahre oder so.
Aber irgendwie hatte ich bei Chico immer im Hinterkopf,
ah, das ist ja noch meine neue Katze.
Aber die ist halt auch schon alt gewesen.
Hat Schilddrüsenprobleme, Nierenprobleme.
Blutwerte.
Chico hatte alles.
Sie hatte vier, fünf Krankheiten.
Also Krankheiten kann man nicht sagen.
Halt.
Ja, doch, Krankheiten.
Also ist nicht durch irgendwie Viren verursacht oder so.
Halt.
All das, all das Probleme.
Wie alt ist sie geworden?
Gute Frage.
Ich glaube 15.
Gebrechen.
Ja, sowas.
Erkrankung.
Ich glaube 15.
Ich werde mir jetzt erst mal keine neue holen.
Ich warte.
Ich warte erst mal.
Ich war.
Ich war erst mal ein bisschen ab.
Weil ich tatsächlich jetzt.
Gemacht habe, ist ich habe an unseren Tierschutz.
Die heißen die Tierschutzverein Seligenstadt oder sowas.
Tierschutz.
Hab ich habe ich ein bisschen Kohle gespendet, jetzt zweimal.
Und ich war auch schon zweimal da.
Und.
Hab mich für eine halbe Stunde.
Bei den Katzen reingehockt.
Und habe ein bisschen Katzen gestreichelt.
Und bin dann halt wieder heim.
Ist halt das Neiße.
Kannst mal ein bisschen Katze streicheln.
Und die.
Die freuen sich ja auch.
Die haben ja auch nicht den ganzen Tag der Ansprache.
Die sitzen da halt rum.
Und.
Haben es da aber ganz schön.
Eigentlich.
Cats as a Service sozusagen.
Ja.
Ich habe das verbunden mit Spendenquittung einsammeln.
Da gibt's auch Chico.
Moment.
Jojo und Chico ist das.
Geboren auch.
Die sind ja noch ganz junge.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Barbie.
Die ich davor hatte.
Von den Augenfarben und der Farbe.
Ja meine.
Die vor Chico hieß Barbie.
Das war die dickste.
Und ähm.
Klobigste Katze von allen die ich bisher hatte.
Aber irgendjemand hat die Barbie genannt.
Alter.
Och ja.
Ich würde die alle nehmen.
Das ist das Problem.
Dann habe ich die.
Chancen da war das nicht.
Ja.
Es gibt leider schon Cats as a Service.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Gut, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Exoskelett ausprobiert.
Guck mal hier, ich bin Iron Man.
So Exoskeletten, also mit so maschinell angetriebenen Roboteranzügen.
Das skippen wir jetzt mal kurz durch.
Gerade auch, weil das in vielen Filmen wirklich beeindruckend aussieht.
Und den Filmhelden, dass es so viele Möglichkeiten gibt.
Und wer will denn nicht stärker sein als in echt?
Was aber auffällt, in fast allen Filmen werden Exoskelette irgendwie militärisch eingesetzt.
Dabei gibt es ganz...
Und was auch auffällt, in fast allen Filmen, wo man Exoskelette sieht, sind sie CGI.
Andere sinnvolle Einsatzmöglichkeiten.
Und ja, und jetzt konnte ich auf der CES in Las Vegas wirklich mal so ein maschinelles Exoskelett...
Ich finde, das kann durchaus Sinn machen, ja.
Gerade wenn du schwere Sachen heben musst und sowas.
Es muss ja, also erstens, es muss ja nicht sein, dass Leute, die körperlich arbeiten,
das nicht bis zur Rente machen können, weil sie komplett im Arsch sind.
Da können sowas...
Oder halt auch bei irgendwelchen Räumungsarbeiten und sonstigen Sachen,
wo du halt Sachen heben musst, die du so mal easy gar nicht hebst.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es da viele Einsatzzwecke für gibt.
Aber...
Ja, oder für Leute, die Probleme haben mit dem Laufen.
Jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt für Leute, die gar nicht mal laufen können,
aber für Leute, die Probleme haben, lange Strecken selbst zu laufen.
Kann ich mir durchaus cool vorstellen.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir aber auch vorstellen kann?
Dass das in, keine Ahnung, Japan...
Wenn es das in Japan gibt, dass wir das erst 20 bis 30 Jahre später bei uns...
...in Deutschland haben, dann...
Weil wir wahrscheinlich wieder 50.000 Sachen dafür neu bürokratisieren müssen,
dass das funktioniert bei uns in Deutschland, dass das eingesetzt werden darf.
Dann brauchen wir bestimmt noch einen Exoskelett-Ethik-Rat und zig Dinger
und alle müssen was zu sagen und irgendwann haben wir das 30 Jahre später als alle anderen.
Sollte das kommen.
...dass zwei verschiedene Modelle von unterschiedlichen Herstellern ausprobieren können.
Ein eher preiskünstiges, dass das Laufen um 20...
Das sieht irgendwie falsch aus, ich weiß nicht.
Sieht ein bisschen nach Kockerhalter aus, aber...
Also das sieht irgendwie falsch aus.
...erleichtern soll und das so klein ist, dass man es in den Rucksack tun kann
und eines, dass in der Pflege und Industrie die Arbeitsbedingungen für das Personal erheblich angenehmer...
Ja, Rücken, guck mal, kriegst du weniger Rückenprobleme.
Ja, genau, sowas wie, du brauchst ein Kennzeichen, aber dann darfst du nur auf Fahrradwegen und was auch immer.
Es wird super abwegig wahrscheinlich in Deutschland wieder werden, sowas einzuführen.
...ein spürbarer Unterschied zu ohne.
Wie das in der echten Welt eingesetzt werden könnte und wie sich das anfühlt, seht ihr gleich.
Bleibt dran.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Okay, das geht mal.
Das geht mal.
Cringe Intro.
Glaube ich jeden Fall.
Der automatisch eure persönlichen Daten aus den Händen von Daten...
Also ich habe auf der CS ja viele neue und beeindruckende Dinge gesehen.
Unter anderem eben auch Exoskelette.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht so unbedingt der Mainstream-Tech-Kram, den alle zu Hause benutzen wollen, aber trotzdem so ein Stück Technik, das...
Ich würde es benutzen, wenn ich eins hätte.
...in Zukunft die Dinge einfacher machen könnte.
Ich wollte sowas jedenfalls unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Da könnte ich mal beispielsweise die ganzen Teile, die von dem einen Baum noch im Garten liegen, selbst heben vielleicht.
Wobei, die sind so übertrieben schwer.
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als könnte ich die nur ansatzweise nicht heben, sondern ich kann die halt so komplett unmöglich nicht heben.
Weil so Baumstammdinger, die wiegen halt, keine Ahnung, 300 Kilo oder sowas.
Da pinkt auch ein Exoskelett in mich.
Weil du musst sie ja immer noch mit deinen Händen halten.
...bei der Firma German Bionic in einer Hotelsuite in Las Vegas.
Sogar mit Ausblick.
Ist German Bionic wirklich German?
Oder haben die einfach nur German im Namen, weil das bei den Amis cool ist, wenn was German ist?
Ne, jetzt hat's...
Augsburg, ne, okay, okay.
Bavaria.
Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen absurd.
Man versucht als deutscher Tech-Journalist das Produkt einer deutschen Firma in Las Vegas auszuprobieren.
Aber gut, dafür ist die CS ja auch irgendwie da.
Erstmal wichtig, was genau habe ich da jetzt eigentlich ausprobiert und von wem?
German Bionic ist, wie der Name schon vermuten lässt, eine deutsche Firma.
Die haben zwar auch Büros in Japan und den USA, aber der Hauptsitz ist im bayerischen Augsburg.
Und dort entwickeln die Exoskelette.
Speziell für die Industrie und für den Einsatz in Pflegeberufen.
Und das macht German Bionic jetzt seit 2017.
Diesen Anzug, den ich hier jetzt anhabe, ist die sechste Geräte-Generation.
Apogee heißt die.
Die wird übrigens auch in Deutschland hergestellt.
Und zwar bei MUBEA in Appendorn im Sauerland.
Übrigens, der Begriff Exoskelett hat mehrere Bedeutungen.
In der Biologie ist das ein Außenskelett, das tatsächlich sehr häufig in der Natur vorkommt.
Nämlich bei nahezu allen Gliederfüßern.
Also Krebstieren, Spinnen, Skorpionen und...
Und bei Rust-Programmierern?
Tausendfüßler.
Wenn ich hier im Video Exoskelett sage, meine ich aber natürlich ein maschinelles Exoskelett.
Also so ein motorisch angetriebenes Skelett.
Das meinem integrierten Endoskelett ein bisschen auf die Sprünge hilft.
Und so ein Exoskelett kann nicht nur meine Kraft verstärken, sondern auch die Beweglichkeit verbessern.
Oder sogar verlorene Fähigkeiten wiederherstellen.
In der Industrie werden Exoskelette eingesetzt, um zum Beispiel bei schweren Hebeaufgaben zu unterstützen.
Oder um die Ausführung von Aufgaben zu erleichtern.
Die über längere Zeiträume hinweg halt ermüdigen.
Ja, diese Haltung sieht auch nicht sehr rückenschonend aus.
Selbst mit Exoskelett.
German Bionic hat Exoskelette für zwei Bereiche.
Eins für die Industrie, das heißt Apotee.
Und eins für den Pflegebereich, das heißt Apotee Plus.
Beide Modelle sind technisch identisch.
Der Unterschied...
Ich bilde mir ein, es gibt ein Audio Interface, was genau so heißt.
Ja, fast.
Liegt nur in der Farbe und darin, dass die Version für die Pflege einfacher zu desinfizieren ist.
Exoskelette machen also im Beruf einen Sinn, in dem man körperlich arbeitet.
Also zum Beispiel für CT3003-Redakteure.
Scherz.
Also ich habe jedenfalls das neueste Modell Apotee Plus ausprobiert, das speziell für Pflegekräfte entwickelt wurde.
Eine Sache, die ich ziemlich nützlich fand, war, dass ich mit dem Exoskelett andere Menschen einfacher hochheben kann.
Und die sich dann noch so an den Griffen festhalten können.
Eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee.
Ein Bett heben.
Das ist ja in der Pflege eine Standardsituation.
Oder?
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
Das Exoskelett wiegt allerdings 6,8 Kilo und das merkt man auch schon beim Anziehen.
Mit Energie versorgt wird das Exoskelett übrigens mit einem handelsüblichen Makita-Werkzeugakku.
Warum nicht?
Bietet sich an.
Sind überall verfügbar.
Easy in Massen zu bekommen.
Mit 2,5 Amperestunden.
Und der soll bis zu 8 Stunden halten und kann während der Benutzung auch so Hotswap-mäßig gewechselt werden.
Anziehen kann man das Exoskelett im Prinzip wie einen Rucksack.
Und ja, dann werden die Motoren gestartet und als letzten Schritt werden noch Teile an den Oberschenkeln festgemacht.
Das sieht hier jetzt noch etwas umständlich aus, aber sowas spielt sich laut German Bionic recht schnell ein und soll nach einigen Malen so etwa 60 Sekunden dauern.
Und das soll man dann auch problemlos alleine hinkriegen.
Bisschen futuristisch ist dieses Display, mit dem man das Exoskelett steuern kann.
Da kann man sich dann per PIN anmelden und dadurch die Einstellungen speichern, auch wenn man sich das Gerät mit anderen Leuten teilt.
Das erste, was ich mit dem Exoskelett gemacht habe, war einfach mal rumlaufen.
Dabei kann man einstellen, wie hoch die Unterstützung sein soll und bei 100% habe ich schon deutlich gemerkt, wie die Motoren meine Beine so nach vorne gezogen haben.
Seitwärts laufen geht übrigens auch, bringt aber weniger Unterstützung.
Und ich muss sagen, das hat halt schon richtig Spaß gemacht.
Ich hätte das gerne mal ausprobiert, mal so eine richtige Wanderung damit zu machen, ob sozusagen die Erleichterung in den Beinen das Gewicht von fast 7 Kilo ausgleichen kann.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das selber so einfach beurteilen kann.
Ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen, es macht großen Spaß.
Zweiter Anwendungsbereich ist das Senken.
Also ich habe etwas in der Hand.
Und will das abstellen oder an einen Patienten hinlegen.
In diesem Fall habe ich es mit einem Wasserkanister ausprobiert.
Und der Unterschied zwischen 0% Unterstützung und voller Unterstützung war auf jeden Fall auch deutlich spürbar.
Als drittes habe ich dann das Heben ausprobiert.
Hier auch mit zwei Kanistern, die je 9 Kilo wiegen.
Und ja, auch hier war der Unterschied deutlich spürbar.
Bei 100% Unterstützung bin ich fast gesprungen vor lauter Kraft.
Die Geräusche, die das Exoskelett macht während der Bewegung, finde ich auch ziemlich cool.
Und so, ja, so robotermäßig halt, ne.
Hört mal selbst.
Noch schwerer war es dann, als ich die Mitarbeiter von German Bionic aus dem Stuhl gehoben habe.
Klar, das habe ich auch ohne Unterstützung geschafft.
Bin jetzt aber auch nicht so klein.
Die Unterstützung habe ich dann aber trotzdem gerne angemacht.
Also Heben und Senken, da ist die Unterstützung noch stärker als im Gehen.
Gehen ist sozusagen so ein Nebenaspekt.
Und diese Heb- und Senkgeschichten, das ist der Hauptanwendungsbereich.
Ich finde, das ist eine echt gute Idee.
Das heißt, dass die Patientinnen und Patienten beim Greifen keine Körperteile einklemmen können.
Was ich technisch interessant finde, das Gerät reagiert im Bruchteil einer Sekunde auf meine Bewegung.
Das heißt, auch wenn ich mitten in der Bewegung stehen bleibe, zieht mich das Exoskelett nicht einfach weiter.
Also Heben, Senken, Laufen, also die drei Bereiche, in denen das Apogee unterstützt,
können auch alle simultan laufen und auch unterschiedlich stark eingestellt werden.
Das merkt sich das Gerät dann eben über die PIN.
Ich kann also sagen, ich hätte gern 50% Unterstützung beim Laufen, beim Heben 75%
und beim Senken will ich 100%.
Was auch ziemlich lustig ist, ist die Gamification.
Also ich kann im Menü Achievements sehen und genau
Na klar!
nachverfolgen, wie viele Kilo Traglast mir das Exoskelett seit dem Anziehen abgenommen hat.
Achievements.
Bionic war nicht der einzige Hersteller von Exoskeletten auf der CES.
Es gab auch noch das Exoskelett von V Robotics.
Also WI Robotics, aber ausgesprochen V.
Das ist jetzt, sage ich mal, etwas einfacher, als das von German Bionic.
Und auch deutlich günstiger.
Und das unterstützt auch nur beim Laufen.
Sieht aus wie eine große Powerbank und man zieht sich das dann einfach so über die Beine und läuft dann los.
Ja, das zeigt noch ein anderes Anwendungsfeld von Exoskeletten.
Das sieht so falsch aus, irgendwie dieses Ding, ich weiß nicht.
Dieses Exoskelett macht das Laufen bis zu 20% einfacher.
Und ja, ich habe da auch ein bisschen was gemerkt beim Ausprobieren.
Aber ob das jetzt 20% waren oder nur 10%, das kann ich natürlich schlecht sagen.
Man merkt aber, dass es nur ein Viertel so viel kostet, wie das von V Robotics.
Die Unterstützung arbeitet nicht so smooth.
Das heißt, dass der Motor manchmal Dinge machte, die sich für mich und meine Beine nicht so natürlich anfühlten.
Aber wie gesagt, die Erleichterung konnte ich spüren.
Und gerade im höheren Alltag könnte sowas ja interessant sein,
einfach um weiterhin beim ausführlichen Spazierengehen oder Wandern dabei sein zu können.
Oder andersrum unterstützt das Modell von V Robotics auch beim Sporttraining
und kann beispielsweise das Laufen unter Wasser simulieren,
also schwerer machen für bestimmte Trainingssituationen.
Okay.
Ehrlich, das brauche ich nicht.
Ist mir schon anstrengend genug, wenn ich da mal eine Runde renne.
Meine Rundenrenne, die muss ich nicht noch künstlich...
Ich kann einfach schneller rennen, wenn es mir nicht anstrengend genug ist.
Die können dann auch per App getrackt und eingestellt werden.
Und so, und jetzt die ganz wichtige Frage.
Was kostet das jetzt eigentlich?
Ja.
Also, die beiden...
Das ist bestimmt schweineteuer.
... Apogee-Modelle von German Bionic kosten 10.000 Euro.
Boah!
Ja, das ist halt für den Profi anwendungslos.
Das ist halt für den Profi anwendungsbereich und noch so ein bisschen Early Adopter-mäßig wahrscheinlich.
Aber das haut halt schon rein, ja.
Es gibt die auch als Robotics as a Service.
Man kann sie also für 400 Euro pro Monat mieten.
Dabei gibt es regelmäßig Software-Updates over the Air.
Jedes Exoskelett hat so ein LTE-Modul und so ein WLAN-Chip.
Das Exoskelett von V Robotics ist eher so ein Alltags- und Sportding, deshalb auch günstiger.
Das sieht so blöd aus irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das sieht einfach verkehrt aus.
Soll in diesem Jahr in den USA auf den Markt kommen und ungefähr 2.500 US-Dollar kosten.
Erscheinungstermin für Europa...
Ja, da hast du recht.
Da hast du recht, ja.
Wenn du dir überlegst, dass die Leute länger arbeiten können, weil sie weniger Bandscheibenprobleme haben und so,
das kann sich durchaus rechnen, ja.
Wenn man das auf größeren Skalen sieht, kann sich das durchaus lohnen.
Gibt es aber noch nicht.
Und wie das bei CES-Produkten manchmal ist, ich würde jetzt nicht meine Hand dafür ins Feuer legen,
dass das Teil wirklich dieses Jahr auf den Markt kommt.
Das ist noch so ein bisschen unklar.
Mein Fazit.
Ich finde auf jeden Fall schon beeindruckend, dass man sich so eine Maschine anzieht.
Das finde ich toll.
Vor allem mit dem Makita-Akku.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Kaste überall.
Gibt es den Massen.
Findest du in jeder Ecke welche.
Kannst du online auch easy bestellen.
Es ist gut, dass es kein eingebauter Akku ist.
So nach dem Motto, ja, dann müsst ihr halt unseren Replacement-Akku kaufen, der zufälligerweise nur 8.000 Euro kostet.
Also, da finde ich gut.
Ich kann mit meinem Körper arbeiten.
Das fühlt sich schon sehr futuristisch an.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass vor allem im Bereich Pflege und auch Logistik, da wo wirklich Körperkraft gebraucht wird,
so ein Exoskelett wirklich sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann.
Das werden die auch schon.
Also ein großer Kunde von German Bionic ist zum Beispiel DPD.
Das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass irgendein Paket von euch schon mal mit Hilfe eines Exoskeletts angehoben oder verladen wurde.
Aber was auch ganz klar ist.
Obwohl das Apogee schon die sechste Generation ist und das Gerät schon viel leichter und unauffälliger geworden ist im Vergleich zur vorherigen Generation.
Man vergisst so ein Exoskelett nicht, wenn man es am Körper trägt.
Das wiegt halt fast sieben Kilo.
Das heißt, man wird die Arbeit, das anzulegen und den ganzen Tag zu tragen, nur aufwenden wollen, wenn es einen wirklich unterstützt bei der Arbeit.
Also wenn ich schon weiß, ich werde heute mindestens 20 mal einen Menschen hochheben oder 30 mal ein schweres Paket aus dem Regal nehmen.
Was ich aber gut und wichtig finde.
Exoskelette ersetzen.
Exoskelette ersetzen keine Menschen.
Das ist in vielen Berufen nämlich gar nicht sinnvoll oder überhaupt möglich.
Stellt euch einfach mal die Frage, würdet ihr im Alter lieber vom Roboter oder echt Menschen gepflegt werden?
Oder wenn ihr umzieht, habt ihr lieber einen Menschen, der eure Kisten trägt oder eine Maschine?
Und dann ist es halt ziemlich gut, wenn es Technik gibt, die in diesen Berufen den Menschenkörper bestmöglich beschützt.
Und auch einfach um Kraft zu sparen.
Also dass man nach so einer acht Stunden Schicht einfach dank so eines geht.
Also ich hätte kein Problem, wenn mein Umzug von einem Roboter gemacht wird.
Wenn das gut funktioniert.
Reds weniger müde ist.
Was meint ihr?
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, auch mal so ein Exoskelett anzuziehen beim Sport?
Ja, echt.
Also ohne Scheiß, wenn es die Möglichkeit gäbe, ich würde es auch ausprobieren.
Zug oder Garten umgraben.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und natürlich auch gerne abonnieren.
Tschüss.
Aber hinknien kannst du damit dich dann aber wahrscheinlich nicht richtig.
Vom Ansatz her mega nice.
Guck mal hier.
Wow.
Nicht draufdrücken.
Ich krieg langsam ab.
Und ich krieg langsam aber sicher mega Hunger.
Ob ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Und wenn MMO Kreiselgrind technisch heute nicht mehr so viel geht.
Dann machen wir das Command Line Tool später weiter.
Ja, was gibt es heute zu essen?
Das ist die Frage.
Es gibt nicht Nudeln mit Lachs, weil Nudeln mit Lachs gab es letzte Woche.
Das heißt, wenn es nicht Nudeln mit Lachs gibt.
Was gibt es dann?
Nudeln mit Bolognese.
Korrekt.
Nudel Tomatensauce.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Deswegen banne ich den Chain doch nicht.
Weiß nicht.
Ich finde seine Sprüche lustig.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es gibt nicht Nudeln.
Es gibt es.
Es gibt nicht Play Nudeln.
Es gibt Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
So.
Ja, wir haben das doch schon so was in der Richtung.
Nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Bist du Vordermittel oder Hinterfußläufer?
Nachdem mich noch nie einer von außen aufgenommen hat, weiß ich es nicht.
Also, ich versuche, so gut wie möglich mittig aufzutreten.
Klappt sicherlich nicht immer.
Aber ich merke, wenn ich versuche ordentlich zu laufen, also das heißt ordentlich von der Haltung her und ordentlich vom Aufsetzen her, dass einem die Beine weniger wehtun und das entspannender ist.
Also, es macht schon ein bisschen Sinn, darauf zu achten, dass man nicht komplett schepp rumrennt.
Lass mich mal kurz in die App gucken.
Da gehe ich was futtern.
Was war denn heute?
Ja, heute war ich nur knapp 50 Minuten unterwegs.
Oh, Garmin sagt, man kann mein Training optimisieren.
Und zwar, sie sagen, okay, hä?
Eben hat es noch gesagt, es kann was verbessern.
Und jetzt sagt es, your current training load is optimal.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ist es optimal oder nicht?
Okay, jetzt sagt es, auf dem nächsten Bild sagt es wieder, dass es nicht optimal ist.
Okay, ich habe zu wenig low aerobic und anaerobic Training.
Ich habe dafür zu viel high aerobic Training.
Okay.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen mehr sprinten und Pause machen und sprinten und Pause machen.
Und ein bisschen mehr lahm rennen.
Ah ja.
Mein Garmin das Energielevel checkte sehn ich.
Und zwar, ich bin mal mit dem Garmin Edge Fahrrad gefahren.
Und der hat mir irgendwann angezeigt, dass mein Energielevel auf 0 ist.
Schon bevor ich daheim war.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay.
Also, und jetzt?
Soll ich jetzt einfach eine Runde pennen hier?
Ne, also das hat er nicht, das ist falsch, wie ich euch das erzählt habe.
Das habe ich erst im Nachhinein in der Statistik gesehen, dass mein Energielevel da schon auf 0 war.
Das lag da dran.
Ich bin gerannt.
Und irgendwie einen Tag später.
Und dann sagt er immer, Erholung 48 Stunden oder sowas.
Und danach bin ich gleich am nächsten Tag, bin ich 52 Kilometer oder wie lange das war, irgendwie Fahrrad gefahren.
Halt mit Berg hoch.
Und das war auch schon.
Anstrengendes Fakt.
Das war das, wo ich nicht die Strecke fahren konnte, wie ich wollte, sondern gleich wieder zurückfahren musste.
Deswegen war die viel länger.
Es war schon anstrengend.
Es war aber nicht bei 0.
Also ich konnte den Tag danach ohne Probleme noch laufen und alles machen.
Also rumlaufen.
Alles machen, was ich wollte.
Ja, das ist nicht immer so hundertprozentig akkurat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so Poggers ist, wenn das so wäre.
Das wäre eher Keck Wade.
Moin Michael.
Du kommst gerade richtig, weil ich gehe jetzt auf was essen.
Ach, du bist schon.
Dann habe ich nicht gesehen.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nein, Spaghetti mit Tomatensoße.
Das ist eine Garmin Watch.
Das ist eine Garmin.
Ball Runner.
255 S.
Finde ich, ist eine gute Kombination aus Preis.
Und was man dafür kriegt.
Weil die Apple Watch so geringe Akkulaufzeit hat.
Die hält ja nicht mal richtig den Tag durch.
Und ich finde es von den Funktionen her auch richtig nice.
Ja, die kostet bei Amazon weniger.
Ist blödsinnig, dass es offizieller Hersteller sei.
Danke.
Guck.
170 Euro.
Ich finde, das ist ein echt ganz okayer Preis.
Für das, was man bekommt.
Hat auch nicht umsonst so viele gute Bewertungen.
Also ich finde die gut.
Ich würde die mir wieder kaufen.
Gerade Customisability ist halt mega.
Und Akkulaufzeit.
Akkulaufzeit ist eine Woche.
Selbst wenn du die ab und zu verwendest.
Nicht so wie bei der Apple Watch, die du permanent aufladen musst.
Also für meine Zwecke finde ich die nice.
Lasst uns gerade noch mal gucken, bevor ich was essen gehe.
Gibt es zu Abwechslung mal wieder Fahrräder in meiner Größe?
Nö.
Meine Größe gibt es angeblich gar nicht mehr.
Tja.
Ich meine, ich habe immer noch kein neues Fahrrad.
Altes ist ja nicht mehr straßentauglich.
Also mein altes.
Mein altes, was ich letztes Jahr im September oder so gekauft habe.
Ja, genau.
Haben die irgendwas neues oder so?
Einfach nicht richtig lieferbar.
Ja.
Ist aber ziemlich kacke so.
Alter, die Seite ist auch echt pepega.
Hier vielleicht was lieferbar.
Ja.
Von denen vielleicht was.
Ne.
Kleine Pfeile nicht mehr.
Das ist mechanisch.
Da habe ich auch keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Wenn man einmal eine elektronische Schaltung hatte, findet man das nice.
Ach ne.
Hier oben.
Ah.
Einmal zwölf mit?
SRAM gibt es?
Gibt es?
Available in seven weeks, Mann.
Ne.
Gibt nichts.
Sad Game.
Ups.
Was will denn YouTube jetzt von mir?
Reject.
Oh.
Das wollte ich nicht aufmachen.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Vielleicht.
Ich will euch nicht zu viel versprechen.
Wenn MMO-technisch heute nicht so viel geht, programmieren wir nachher das CLI-Tool weiter.
Eigentlich habe ich da richtig Spock drauf.
Ich habe auch schon die ersten Beta-Tester auf der Arbeit.
Die das verwenden.
Und es funktioniert bis jetzt auch.
Sollen wir was ordentliches draus basteln.
Okay.
Alles klar, Leute.
Bis vielleicht später.
Wir sehen uns.
CU.
Ciao.